alex has just completed his graduation
from stanford university
one fine day he receives a mail from
star trek technologies for an interview
for the designation of a software
engineer as referred by the university
alex was really happy and excited about
this and starts preparing for his
interview next week while he was
preparing alex came across the term
downtime
alex has no idea
what is a downtime
he decided to seek help from his uncle
john the software engineer
john explained that downtime is a
specific time frame allocated to deploy
or update changes for a software product
in a real-time environment
and this happens because most of the
softwares we use today are developed
using the waterfall model
for example
cisco one of the popular leaders in it
and networking globally is using agile
methodology for their subscription
billing platform sbp
as it was originally developed using the
waterfall model
after adopting the agile methodology
cisco's product improved its overall
efficiency where defects were reduced by
40 percent compared to the previous
releases
and effect removal efficiency increased
by 14
upon explaining what downtime is john
further added that downtime is a small
part of the waterfall model
it is the traditional way of developing
softwares using a software development
lifecycle where the whole product is
treated as one single unit and the
development of one phase starts only
after the completion of the previous
phase
adding new features or updating the
existing feature in a waterfall model
based product needs a specific time
frame known as downtime to avoid
disturbance in the workflow of an
organization we're applying changes in a
waterfall-based product might produce
irrelevant results or product failure
the waterfall model is the earliest or
the traditional model used for software
development where the output of one
phase acts as the input for the
preceding phase
consisting of a series of steps where
each phase has specific deliverables
that act as the input for the next space
as it avoids overlapping of phases as
these phases are dependent on each other
this method is simple and easy to
understand where prerequisites are
pre-known documented earlier and
technology remains static where there is
no need for ambiguous requirements due
to the delay in software delivery
in contrast the final version is
available only after completing the
entire software lifecycle process with
any deviations if available
changes in the waterfall model contain
high risk as changes include a new
revised version of the entire software
running the entire series of steps again
and again
for example
a tap and pay machine where the machine
first validates whether the customer's
account is funded with sufficient funds
or not and then initiates the
transaction for money transfer
unless the validation is processed the
transaction cannot be initiated
alex was curious and asked uncle john is
there any way to overcome the drawbacks
of the waterfall model
john replies yes agile methodology was
introduced to overcome the problems
faced in the waterfall model where agile
based products are developed by breaking
the entire product process into
microservices or phases
which is faster to execute and deploy
changes on the go
there is no need to worry about other or
previous tasks while working on one
particular phase avoiding product
failure
agile based products don't require any
particular time frame downtime to deploy
changes
unlike the waterfall model where the
whole product is treated as one single
unit and each process is dependent on
the preceding processes where deploying
changes leads to downtime how agile
products are developed
agile based products are developed using
the agile life cycle
at first the developed product is
implemented in an actual working
environment for reviews from clients and
stakeholders to check its deliverables
and functionality
after client reviews the official
product is launched in a real-time
working environment where agile
methodology focuses on satisfying the
consumer needs by efficiently utilizing
the resources and avoiding additional
risks or deviations in the product
for example
providing a trial beta version of the
software for the end user to experience
the software towards its deliverables
and results will be helpful in refining
and reviewing the product like adobe
photoshop adobe illustrator etc
after understanding all about agile
methodology
alex asks uncle john
are companies implementing agile in
their workspace nowadays
john replies yes
companies are moving towards agile
methodology due to its flexibility and
advantages over traditional systems
by adopting agile for their sony
interactive environment sony noticed a
major difference where there was a
reduced planning time by 28 with their
framework and downtime was reduced to
the maximum which made the company save
30 million dollars a year so here's a
question for you
what makes agile different from
waterfall model a it is dependent on
microservices
b
agile consumes more time
c
the process is broken down into several
phases
d
none of the above
please give it a thought and post your
answers in the comments section below
three lucky winners will receive amazon
gift vouchers
agile methodology aims to meet the
consumer's requirements to the maximum
in deploying changes in a rapidly
developing environment
where agile manifesto principles brings
an innovative set of rules and protocols
to help developers overcome the
challenges faced in the traditional
practices waterfall model
making agile flexible and efficient
welcome to agile tutorial from simply
learn i am cmr chandra mr a professional
consultant and coach certified agile
scrub master pmp principal practitioner
itl for managing professional kobit 5
and devops
as part of this video tutorial we are
going to understand what is agile the
basic details one should know about
agile
to understand this better let us look at
a time in the late 90s what was
happening with software development
forms
so they used to follow waterfall
methodologies
so there used to be expression like said
we have a problem so what happened
so our client want a new feature to the
software we are already midway creating
the software we can't add the feature
so what does it mean
so there is a scenario where the change
is asked
so why change change may be because of
adding certain features removing certain
features modifying certain things
already given what is wrong in that why
can't we do the change so now point here
is not about doing the change itself
it's about the effort additionally it
takes
cost money
in terms of which is going out the
effort then
the scope which is going to change at
the same time you also need to put more
efforts which will delay the project
so now is it okay so 90s it was okay
today is it okay a big question mark so
why is that not okay
so we need to understand that very
clearly
right
i knew we should not have used the
waterfall methodology for development so
is that an issue with the waterfall
methodology
so answer is no
if it is today's scenario answer would
be yes if it is 90s answer would be no
so what changed in this 20 years or 15
years
the dynamics of the market changed the
behavior of consumers changed so if you
look at anyone who is using any product
it may be a software product or a
hardware
like if your mobile phone or a
television or any application mobile
application or application used on your
systems the upgradation of the new
features and functionality of that is
improved more and more and consumer
wants it more and you have a very less
time to respond that is one thing
second thing there is lot of competition
if you do not respond quickly
competition will take over so for you to
sustain and grow it is very essential
that you understand this dynamics and
you need to respond quickly which was
bit difficult when it comes to approach
what is called waterfall model now how
do we address this so what is that
waterfall model is all about why is it
difficult for us
so the methodology where waterfall model
is used involves teams following a
series of steps and only going forward
after the previous steps are completed
so there is a wait time involved so
until the previous steps are completed
only then i can move to the next
so it is a slower thing
it would take certain longer duration
so it is best used in the scenarios
where the teams are small and the
project is expected to move in a
predictable manner so predictability is
very important when we follow waterfall
methodology predictability the variation
should be as lesser as possible so what
is the predictability i'm speaking about
as i create this product as a result
comes up if it takes six months one year
two years three years it's okay
so this is how the product would look
like the predictability how the product
would look like how that particular
output would come so when is that going
to come is it okay
if i bring that result after two years
is that okay
so if everything is okay that way
without very less without any variations
as such very less variations then it's
fine
so because of following waterfall model
what is that methodology what is that
flow
we need to understand that so
requirements gathering and documentation
is the first thing what used to happen
which is true in agile methodologies
also but the main difference here is the
requirements gathering and documentation
happens in detail a comprehensive one
now once that is signed off only then it
is moved to the design now based on that
requirement which is gathered which is
full comprehensive
then the design will happen based on
that the consideration of process the
products the people
the environment then the design happens
which is again a detailed design now
once the implementation starts
if you find any deviations the
correction needs to be done since the
design is in detail the deviation
possibility is as less as possible
but the challenge comes up when the
dynamics in the market when the dynamics
of customer changes
customer asks for change then you may
require to do the change now when you
want to do that change you might require
to do the change only after
understanding what would be the impact
of this change in the entire output
which you are going to create which is
very comprehensive one so because of
this it consumes time it consumes extra
effort so it may be a scenario where the
scope of work is reduced as well even
after that this exercise has to be done
which will delay the project so this was
okay so when this model when
things were done things were taken up
for changes it was okay because the
consumer behavior as i mentioned there
is a lot of wait time for the consumers
also so there was less competition but
today it is not i need to go quicker
so because of this what are the
disadvantages which just came up to the
consumers or to the organization who
actually follow waterfall methodologies
in today's scenario so what could be
those so making changes would be
difficult as i mentioned earlier
so then it doesn't focus on end user
client customer perspective value so
today i think more and more we're
speaking about creating a value in the
consumer perspective customer
perspective
and the time it takes for consumer to
realize the value how long it takes the
more it delays in realizing the values
by the consumer there is a delay in
terms of making your product impression
better in the consumer's mind so
competition will take over so your
existence will be in bigger threat
so
testing phase is delayed until most of
the project is completed because it has
to follow step by step wait the things
to complete and then testing happen
then measuring the progress within the
stages is difficult so why is it
difficult measuring the progress within
the stages because the deliverables or
the metrics what are defined are defined
to measure at a milestone and at a end
of the phase to understand whether
everything is delivered as part of it
now let us look at how agile is going to
help us to address these disadvantages
mentioned in what fall model so what is
agile the basic meaning of agile is to
move faster be flexible respond to
change etc but to accomplish this there
are a lot of methodologies
now there is something called agile
manifesto on 12 principles of agile
which we need to understand so following
this accomplishing this can only help us
in becoming a child
so in 2001 agile was introduced so
that's where the term agile came into
picture where people start realizing
what is a child and why should we adopt
that agile methodologies
so while it was introduced
so agile manifesto was also released
it's a set of principles used in project
management and software development so
basically there are four points which we
need to understand very correctly very
clearly so that we can able to
understand what is agile is all about
right it enables team to deliver value
to their customers with ease so agile
team deliver work in small but usable
increments then evaluation of the
requirements plans and results takes
place continuously this allows teams to
respond to changes quickly now change
was one of the scenario what we were
speaking about now responding to change
quickly is one of the disadvantages what
we spoke about and here it is addressed
it is considered to address that is very
important now when we respond to change
quickly it is not that i just quickly
responded but i did not address that
problem or that scenario it is very
essential to address that scenario as
well effectively and efficiently
so now agile is a concept right so it
has a detailed manifesto based on which
all the agile methodologies are created
so what is this agile manifesto is all
about so it is created it was created
during february 2001 so which details
out the values and principles of agile
processes
which says there are some values which
is mentioned in the left
which has more weightage compared to the
one which is in the right now when we
say this for example let us take let us
go one by one
individuals and interactions over
process and tools so are we saying we
don't value the process and tools that
is not the case now let us look at what
were the typical
issues or challenges anyone would have
expressed regarding the processes
so delay may be bureaucracy and
they cannot have a flexibility to move
faster so basically delays because of
the approval which is not happening
because of the processes
now how do we address this so can i
eliminate the process itself answer is
no because in the absence of tools and
processes
none of the
things which we can do easily can exist
so it should be there process and tools
should be there
the way it should be defined it should
also ensure that is individuals and
interactions encouraged to have their
individuals and interactions while
having the process and tools so next is
working products or comprehensive
documentation
so when we say comprehensive
documentation as i mentioned in the
waterfall methodology during the
requirement gathering during designing
there is a detailed documentation which
is made so which take lot of efforts in
creating those now while delivering the
challenge what anyone was faced was the
change which is coming up and making
changes to these documentations which is
an additional effort now if we have a
working products if i have a bigger
product
in that a module of that i keep creating
every small small modules of it and
start integrating to the base model now
i will only focus on the documentation
for that particular model working piece
which i am going to create in the next
iterations
then my documentation changes are less
and also the way i'm making the
documentation is initially i would have
a full skeleton of the entire product
which i am going to create the roadmap
and upon that i am going to making the
detailed documentation for that only for
that working piece rather than the full
product itself then these working piece
documentation which i am going to create
as i create the working pieces i am also
getting the feedback because i am doing
the interactions with the users the
consumers the end users so get the
feedback i keep making the changes
quickly and then documentation will
become accordingly
the small pieces of documentation which
happens with those small small small
working models which are created and
those are consolidated over a period of
time
by the time the product ends you have a
comprehensive documentation the project
hands you have a comprehensive
documentation so it
saves lot of time
so documentation is important but the
way we accomplish the documentation is
one by one not in one go
next is customer collaboration or
contract negotiation
so any engagement or any relationship or
any business can it happen in the
absence of contract answer is no there
should be a contract now how this
contract should be when we want to
follow an agile it should allow the
customer collaboration why are we
collaborating to understand what
customer is required to understand what
customer needs is fulfilled right
so now this requires a lot of
flexibility in the contract itself so
that commercial is one area which gets
impacted and there should be guidelines
for that also in the contract
so that during the collaboration during
the change during the effort being put
customer is also informed what is the
change which is going to happen in terms
of commercial as well as time and
everything so that it is documented in
the contract so there is no confusion
responding to change or following a plan
now we cannot have a rigid plan as we
were speaking about waterfall
methodologies so that we need to go like
this only
so based on the scenarios changes so
we'll be required to change your
directions and move faster so responding
to change requires a specific
flexibility which is required in the
plan so that you i don't have a plan
which is very rigid and that provides
some flexibility that's how i can able
to create my plan so that i can able to
move
or respond to that specific scenarios
which are changing
so this is called agile manifesto and
this agile manifesto has 12 principles
associated with this
now keeping this agile manifest on 12
principles all the agile methodologies
have created their own approaches and
framework now let us look at what are
those 12 principles the agile principles
so agile principles so here are some of
principles that need to be followed to
make a processes agile
so first principle is about customer
satisfaction so one need to satisfy the
customer through early and quick
delivery of the product now someone who
is hungry if you give them a water or a
food immediately a piece of bread at
least there is some satisfaction there
is some realization as i got it what i
need so energy is back
so it is very much required to ensure
seeing things in a customer perspective
and customer is satisfied so customer
satisfaction is not a result of the
survey what i do it's about how i deal
with the consumer what is that impact
the perceptions i'm building with the
consumer and what do i know about my
customer do i really understand the
pulse of my customer how associated am i
how close am i how am i collaborating
with the customer that will help you to
understand how satisfied your customer
is
it is very essential to consider
customer satisfaction and the second
principle would be welcome change
so changing needs need to be addressed
even late in the development process so
change can happen anytime
now these changes should not become a
challenge so there should be a
flexibility in your design itself which
will bring in so that is the reason i
think when you move faster
so it doesn't mean that you eliminate or
you just keep introducing the defects
and move faster no that is not allowed
so whenever there is a change in the
feature whenever there is a change to
some specific product functionality
accommodating that should become easier
whatever the methodology i follow
that should help me in terms of
accommodating so i should be welcoming
changes it's okay for me to have the
change so that is not a challenge
anymore for me
so principle three
deliver frequently
so ensure software is delivered
frequently focusing on shorter time
scales as i was mentioning while
discussing the manifesto point
like i keep creating a smaller piece of
product modules so that i keep putting
into the base model and integrating
those and ultimately once all the
features functionalities are integrated
we have a product with all the features
and functionality
so this needs to happen more frequently
so the release of those working p should
happen more frequently more repeatedly
so that customer is seeing those working
piece and experiencing and giving their
feedbacks so quick changes to those
working piece making that will become
easier
then work together so when i work
together it is very essential that
developers and business individuals need
to work together through the course of
project which means involvement of
customers involvement of suppliers
involvement of your own team
everyone should work together each one
should understand each other's
perspective view if there is no proper
understanding about each other's
perspective view it is quite obvious
what was expected what was delivered
would not match so there should be
correct understanding to have that
correct understanding one should work
together collaborate
so they should speak express which is
very important so feedback has to be
given by consumers regularly
similarly the organization who is doing
the project should also keep giving the
feedbacks to the suppliers to make
necessary changes
and once it works together in a unison i
think that would help in terms of
bringing out the results the way it is
required that would help customer to get
the value
motivated team so projects need to build
around motivated individuals and they
must be trusted to get the job done
means when will the team get motivated
when the work what they are doing is
acknowledged
when the work what they are doing the
results are seen experienced and then
feedback is given there is an
opportunity for learning and
contribution their contribution is
acknowledged only then team is motivated
when there is a motivated team when team
feels there is someone with whom they
can look up to it's quite obvious team
will also come up with certain set of
innovation in their mind
giving their feedback as well
involving themselves in terms of getting
the results what is required so it is
always essential to ensure the team
which is involved in creating the
products is always motivated so i think
when we say team the conflict also come
across there may be a clash between the
various different thoughts and
preferences so one cannot just shy away
being a manager one cannot shy away from
it he or she should involve sit with the
team resolve those put things in the
right direction so right lead
interpersonal skills are very important
here
next face to face interactions so which
helps in terms of most efficient means
of communication which helps in terms of
giving a proper clarity in terms of what
is required so that i sent an email i
expect the person to do it that is not
the case what we are discussing about so
more and more interactions which should
happen face to face so that each other
understand what requires to be done and
there is a quick feedback which can
happen when that particular interactions
conversation which keeps happening so
one can understand other perspective
view as well
and working software so it is a
primarily the deliverable which you are
speaking about which has to come
regularly so more and more working peace
as it comes customer can give feedback
based on their experience on this
working piece instead of just imagining
something and then giving the feedback
so it should not look like an hypothesis
or something which is in the dreamland
so i told something the person would
heard visualize something else it should
not end up that way instead of that give
the working piece expect the consumer
the user to give the feedback so that it
helps in terms of creating that
particular product ultimately which is
usable and which is going to create
value to the consumers
so next is constant pace
so agile process promotes sustainable
development so it should not i did it
and i sleep i did it and then i'm
waiting for something else no
there should be frequent deliverables
which is happening so there should be
constant moment from left to right from
beginning to end so that the
deliverables which are expected keeps
happening so that consumers or users are
realizing the value of it so it should
be constant pace the velocity the speed
which needs to be adopted
then good design
agility can be improved by focusing on
technical excellence and good design so
when we say technical excellence and
good design it is very essential to
understand insight towards what is that
product being delivered insight towards
what is the technology being used
insight towards the processes the
capabilities skills so all this comes
together when people sit together and
focus on creating that product or
services
so they are putting the effort towards
designing it appropriately so that that
will fit for purpose
so since things are moved step by step
in terms of creating a working piece
the detailed designing of that small
working piece would happen which can
happen quicker as well and since these
are going and fitting into the
architecture which is basically open
architecture kind of scenarios what
you're speaking about so all those
modules what to create you keep plugging
into it
so that you were designing that small
piece which is quicker so instead of
designing the entire system as a whole
in detail you're just creating the small
pieces and fitting into that
architecture which is open so pluggable
so that gives flexibility as well and
changes to the design will become easier
if it's not working
and agility helps in accomplishing that
simplicity the amount of work that's not
being done needs to be minimized
meaning when we say simplicity doesn't
mean less
right so the appropriate number of tasks
the minimum number of tasks it needs to
be done and mostly i think all non-value
adding activities and processes would be
removed it has to be removed so the more
optimized more simpler in terms of
handling things is always good
so that only those what is required to
be done are done so it is very clearly
visible and there will be clarity
self-organization so when we say
self-organized teams who is not capable
of everything but when you look at a
team has a whole each one has different
different skills many skills not one or
two skills many skills which they are
complementing to each other so they come
together they discus together they focus
on the architectures requirements and
design and address it together so team
is also owning the ownership is one
thing when it comes to picture when you
say team so here since team is actually
taking up that ownership and organizing
themselves to accomplish the results the
products what is required so then
obviously the results will happen the
way it is needed and they will become
accountable as a team so they cannot
have a blaming scenario where because of
one or two members it is happening they
should collaborate better they should be
self-organizing what should happen
so next is reflect and adjust
so when are we going to reflect reflect
upon what is that happening learn
understand keep learning it having a
reflection to that what is happening
means responding to that so that
improvement can happen quicker
effectiveness can be improved by the
team regularly reflecting on it so team
is also understanding team is also
having that accountability to ensure
that necessary adjustments necessary
actions are taken to make those changes
and connections quickly
so these are about 12 principles so
which supports which helps that
accomplishment of manifesto points
the four manifesto points what is
mentioned so keeping these four
manifesto points four values which is
mentioned in manifesto and then 12
principles
so keeping these in mind any agile
methodologies have their own approaches
and they accomplish all of this
so further let us look at some of the
advantages what would be there when
following agile so we looked at the
disadvantages what we have when we
follow waterfall so did we overcome
those the disadvantage is what we had in
waterfall did we overcome that using
agile so what are the advantages of
agile
so agile
is helpful in terms of handling large
amounts of interactions between client
and project team because it is throwing
lights on it's the importance of
interactions the importance of
collaboration the what is that
self-organized teams it is spoken more
and more
then improve transparency to claims in
every phase of the project how this
transparency because customer is seeing
those products the products with
features and functionalities are seen
they are experiencing it and based on
that they are given the feedback there
is nothing something hidden like when i
go with waterfall
till the end of the project customer
don't know what is going to come out as
a whole but here since the working piece
is given regularly
customer is seeing it the users are
using it and giving their feedback so
interactions increased so visibility
towards what we are creating results is
more
right
then the delivery of the output is
predictable and can sometime be earlier
than expected because we know what is
being delivered more and more clarity
users are obtaining at the same time the
team which is creating is obtaining
because of it the pulse of the customer
the directions are clear accommodating
changes which was the challenges in it
was a big challenge in waterfall
methodology has become easier here
so then the cost of the project are
predictable and follow a rigid schedule
so it is very easy to handle the
schedules because more and more you
interact and more iterations or in
creation of small small working piece of
a product working model of the product
so now as you progress in that you
understood the environment better you
understood the clients better the
customers better
the expectation better and moving faster
so that will become easier for you now
you have become predictable you can
predict easily what is that going to
happen ultimately so more and more
visibility you start getting so handling
things will become easier
so then it allows for changes to refine
and re-prioritize the product backlog so
when i say product backlog we need to
understand the various different user
stories what is written to deliver so
that is a list of deliverables product
backlog what are there since we already
know what other things needs to be
created so this helps in terms of
prioritizing those changing the
priorities based on the change scenario
and then taking the pace taking the
speed accordingly
the client can provide the priority of
features allowing the team to ensure
maximum project value so since it is
visible what are the user stories what
are the effects written what is that
order priorities order of priority what
we are kept now the change scenario
obviously tells us do we really need to
change this priority of which feature
has to be done first so that will become
easier because you have the list only
changing that order in the list and then
going forward accordingly integration is
not an issue because we have the base
model which can integrate all of this
together with no issues now then by
focusing on needs of the users the team
can deliver value to the customers so
users are involved more often
so user pulse is understood what user
requires is clearly understood so
delivering that value to the customer
will become more easier and simpler so
then project is broken into smaller
units with high quality development
testing and collaboration because you
have the flexibility so since you have
better visibility you can able to do
this and you move one by one iteration
by iterations you progress further
so those were the advantages of adopting
agile now
keeping that agile manifesto on 12
principles of manifesto
so what are the types of typical agile
methodologies would come across so there
are few which we are going to look at as
part of it which we need to know so
these agile methodologies definitely
considers the agile manifesto points and
then they demonstrate it in their own
way
now agile methodologies perspective let
us go one by one
so
some of them to look at the first one is
xp that is extreme programming so this
is the framework that enables teams to
create high quality software and
improves their quality of life
so it enables software development with
appropriate engineering practices
so and then when is it applicable
so it is applicable to the scenario
where changing software requirements to
handle risks caused due to new
technology while working with a small
extended development team to use
technology to allow automated unit and
functional tests so that is about
extreme programming
so next let us look at kanban so kanban
is a methodology which is used to design
manage and improve the flow of system it
is actually called as pull system so
visual system so everything which is
actually put on a board and it is
visible to everyone what work need to be
done what is in progress who has to do
it is very clearly visible so
organizations can visualize their flow
of work and the limiting their work in
progress so what is limiting what is
stopping is clearly visible so generally
if i look at whenever i'll just take a
scenario of
a meeting and minutes of meeting which
always discuss about it
now when there is a minutes of meeting
shared with many people who have
participated in the meeting there are
certain action items given to them for
example
now these action items i will have a
target day to complete and accordingly
those needs to be closed
now when the next meeting happens when
you look at the action item status
majority of them are not addressed what
could be the reason is that people are
not sensitive about answering or
addressing those
so more than that the prioritization
changes
so one important thing we need to
understand how kanban works here is it
is a visual system compared to that
minutes of meeting which is not visible
to us always
the kanban board is visible to us always
so one which is visible to us always
makes us put a conscious effort to close
it because our name is indicated on the
board the work need to be completed is
mentioned against our name then we need
to take it up and then close it
so it pushes it it will put a conscious
effort because it is visible and i
cannot build any storage telling that
why i did not do why did i not consider
this as a priority rather than consider
something else as a priority so this
kanban strategy addresses it and then
it's also called as pull system because
people pull the work from it and then
complete
right so where is this applicable
it can be used in situations where work
arrives in an unpredictable fashion so
that means it gives a lot of flexibility
in terms of adopting to the changes
which are happening the dynamics
environment
so it is also used to deploy work
immediately without waiting for other
work items so since it is visible i
think things can go smoother easier so
that people are owning it rather than
just disowning it so now let us look at
lean so when we say lean it is very
important for us to understand
that value is always in customer
perspective and elimination of waste
these are the two things mainly spoken
about
so lean is a set of tools and principles
that aims to identify and remove waste
to increase the speed of process
development
it focuses on maximizing the value to
the client ensuring waste is minimized
so
when you look at visualize a processes
process interfaces and the flow
so the interface certain way so unless
the output of one process or procedure
is getting into an another process so
that flow should be smoother like many
pipes connected together and water is
flowing so let us assume series of pipes
which is of around
one feet in terms of diameter of each of
the pipes
water is flowing in between if you have
a pipe which is off half a feet now what
happens to the downstream after that
half feet pipe the entire capacity in
the downstream even though it has one
feet diameter pipe it leads to the waste
under utilized capacity because this has
become bottleneck now such bottlenecks
such the one which contributes to the
waste has to be eliminated
that is very important so value should
be seen in the consumer perspective
and that value would happen only through
the series value streams
then in this value stream the
identification of the constraints and
bottlenecks and elimination of waste now
what are the contributors of waste so
waiting time
more often changing things moving from
one place to another place
allowing defects to flow which leads
towards a rework
so all this likewise many things which
actually end up in giving the ways so
one has to visualize understand realize
what are those non-valuing activities
and eliminating those is very important
right
so now when is it applicable
lean principles apply to any sector
where there is waste of any form so it
can be applied easily so one is to know
that so it should effort which needs to
be put with the objective to accomplish
so your ability to move faster your
ability to create that product which is
more efficient so only you can achieve
it the effective results can happen only
when there is a lesser delays or lesser
waste non-valuing activities that needs
to be understood and eliminate those
so next one of the populace methodology
would be scrum
so scrum is a framework that is used by
teams to establish a hypothesis trying
it out reflect on the experience and
digest it is used to enable teams to
incorporate practices from other
frameworks depending on the team's
requirement
it's a simple framework which speaks
about a product owner
a scrum master a self-organizing team
so some of the terminologies what it
uses is sprint daily scrum product
backlog sprint backlog
so it's very essential to understand
this framework simpler and able to adopt
it is also very easy when is it
applicable it is used when
cross-functional teams are working on
product development when work is split
into more than one two to four week
iterations
so these iterations are called as
sprints small time box iterations so
this will also help in terms of
accomplishing the results provides that
flexibility and able to move faster then
crystal
so crystal is an approach to the
software development that focuses on
people and their interactions rather
than tools and processes
it is aimed to streamline processes and
improve optimization it works on
principle that projects
are unique and dynamic each requiring
its specific methods
so where is it applicable
it focuses on strengthening teams
communication it also focuses on
continuous integration active user
involvement and configurable processes
so these are the few agile methodologies
which are there which are more popular
more heard however we can come across
many other methodologies like safe agile
which is a scaled scenario for more
complex projects so likewise we have
many methodologies
which organizations adopt and these are
few for us to understand
as part of this tutorial we are going to
understand the basic understanding
requirements of scrum
the agile methodology
so let us look at the problem scenario
what was there in the absence of
adoption of agile in any given
environment
so in the given scenario there is a
problem expressed
so we have a problem our consumer
doesn't like our product we will have to
make changes immediately
so now as usual any manager would
respond
the manager says make the changes
so because it's always
the changes or anything what we deliver
is in the consumer's interest so keeping
consumers interest in mind the value it
needs to be created for customers any
changes required to be done in any of
our projects
involving that consumers and customers
we may require to do the change
so but what is the problem here to do
the change so we can't we already have
started work on last batch
the waterfall model we follow doesn't
let changes to be made midway through
the process
so is it mean the waterfall model never
allows the changes to happen
that is not true hundred percent
waterfall model allows us to make
changes but
it doesn't allows us to make the changes
quickly so whenever there is a change
it requires lot of effort
it requires changes in documentation it
asks for the changes in various
different implementations which has
already done which is executed already
and then lot of efforts are involved
which is time consuming and also it
involves more cost now how do we make
the change which is required to the
customer and at the same time we don't
have any specific additional effort
which are required so these efforts
whatever is being put is acceptable to
both the parties both the stakeholders
that is
the project organization as well as the
customer so how do you make it happen
quickly as well that is very important
for us
so we should have used the agile
methodologies so meaning agile
methodology helps us to do this
so one of the
agile methodologies which we are going
to look at as part of this tutorial is
scrum so let us see how scrum is going
to help the scenario so scenario of
changes which are coming up more
frequently right
right before that let us understand what
is the meaning of agile what is the
meaning of agile
what it means and why should we adopt
agile
so agile means moving faster being
flexible
responding to the changes
now agile is a set of methods and
practices that focuses on iterative
development why iterative in each
iterations
agile methodologies helps us to create a
working piece of the software product
which will help us to make quick
corrections to those software piece this
is not a whole product it is part of
that bigger product
so requirements and solutions are
obtained
thanks to self-organizing
cross-functional teams collaborating so
when we say cross-functional team
self-organizing team so these are the
teams which are seven plus or minus two
the size of the team what i'm speaking
about who basically have various
different skills each of the team
members will have various different
skills
and they complement to it i think today
the devops is speaking about this
cross-functional team owning everything
as a single team some of the
organizations has already demonstrated
their devops capabilities by having this
approach like having self-organizing and
cross-functional team having an
accountability for the entire product
the particular piece of the product
module what they have created so this
helps in improving accountability and
also ensures
better visibility of the product what is
being
created and delivered
so
further let us look at the advantages of
using agile so what it gives to us how
it helps so now the organization who
follows the gel methodologies so we can
see that projects follow a predefined
schedule and have a predictable cause
so schedules are seen
but wherever there is a changes required
wherever these directions need to be
changed
in terms of making necessary changes to
adopt to the
required scenario the change scenario
agile helps us it gives that
so clients have visibility of each phase
of project so it is very essential
whosoever adopts the agile methodology
the active involvement of customer has
to be ensured so they are actively
involved so customers or clients
actively involved in the sense they know
it what is happening what they are
getting they know they are acknowledging
it by giving the feedbacks every now and
then so that there is no surprise to
them at the end which used to happen
during waterfall approaches
then greater interaction between project
team and the project
means there needs to be collaboration
agile emphasizes on having the
collaboration so scrum in specific have
something called daily scrum where 15
minutes meeting where entire scrum team
should come in
sit together
self-organizing team as well as all that
agile teammates to come together express
what they have completed before the last
daily scrum meeting and what is spending
why is it pending and what is that they
are going to do before the next meeting
so all these are expressed this will
help the team as well as the scrum
master as well as the product owner the
visibility into what is complete what
needs to be completed and this will help
project manager or scrum master to
provide the necessary inputs better
visibility to the customers and
stakeholders as well
product output is predictable and can
sometimes happen earlier than expected
so now initially as we know so the
visibility of anything what we do will
be very less
so now as we discuss more and more as we
brainstorm more and more the visibility
into it will become more then what would
happen in future the ability to predict
will also become easier and this doesn't
happen only with the project team it
also happens with customers and every
stakeholders who are involved in the
project
so next high quality development testing
and collaboration is ensured since the
project is broken down
so now each iterations each module each
piece of software which is being created
are tested regularly feedbacks are
obtained from the user as well active
involvement of user are ensured so that
they are acknowledging it
so the what customer needs are given
so it is not that i discovered something
which i did not need i i'm seeing it i
told something i'm getting something
that scenario is eliminated
then the product backlog can be refined
and reprioritized
so since we move iteration wise
depending on the change scenario
depending on the directions changes we
can keep reordering or reprioritizing
our product backlog what needs to be
created first if have one two three four
five item i can make it as three four
one two five
so depending on the change scenario
whenever it needs to be executed it is a
bit flexible and easy to do
then teams can maximize project value
since clients can provide project
priority so as we know the visibility
also increases to the consumer as well
as all the stakeholders they will also
express
what is that value
they have seen from this and this will
also help in making a decision should we
continue with this project or should we
not so better visibility better decision
making better value realization
the needs of the customer can be focused
on increasing the value delivered so as
customer gives the feedback as that
visibility increases then a customer is
getting that value and then expressing
what is the changes what is that
additionally they may required here how
can make it better so these interactions
can happen
so customer can be focused on increasing
the value delivery so in fact i think
earlier we used to speak about time to
market today we're speaking about time
to value which means how quickly uh the
consumers the users or customers
realizes the value is that benefit
realized so that's what the more and
more discussion which is happening which
requires closer collaboration with
consumers and their feedbacks their
experiences with the products or
services which are being used by them it
is very essential to understand
so then various different methodologies
what we have in agile we can speak about
scrum kanban extreme programming that is
xp
lean methodologies the crystal
so now in this video tutorial we are
actually focusing on scrum so let us
understand what is this scrum is all
about
right so before we go and understand
what is the scrum itself so let us look
at the history of scrum where it started
how it started
so right down the line during 1986 the
name scrum is first introduced by the
management experts
yukujiro nanaka and hirotakat kuchi
so japanese
so now this terminology introduced but
later in 1995
jeff sutherland and ken schubert
creates the early version of what would
become the agile methodologies
so now earlier 1995 so need for agile
was sensed and it was spoken about i
mean why do we need a gel methodologies
in future what would be the future
organization which would look like so
that would trigger in terms of what kind
of approaches we may require to have
so
further 2001 the agile alliance is
founded and first look on scrum the
agile software development with scrum is
published
so then further down the line 2002 the
scrum alliance is founded by weber and
certifications are added then later 2006
the scrum link is created the certified
scrum courses are taught
so people started getting certified on
scrum
then later 2009 scrum dot org is created
which offers the professionals scrum
series of certifications
then 2010 the first scrum guide is
published so which made available to
everyone so from then i think the more
and more people start adopting scrum
methodologies now interesting part is
the journey started from 1980s till 2010
various changes which has happened to
this particular methodology but one
thing we should keep in mind is
same 20 years back or 15 20 years back
if we go
the need for a jail was not seen so it
was spoken but need for a gel was not
spoken much but today we're speaking
about it more and more the reason is i
think the change in the market condition
the increase in the competition
the need of responding to the change
which is asked by the consumers of the
market variations has become more and
more important for organizations and
service providers if they don't respond
to the change they may lose out in the
competition so their survival is at
stake so it is very essential for them
to understand this dynamics and respond
to those scenarios quickly so that's
where the adoption of agile the benefit
of adopting a jail were realized and
scrum become popular
so what is scrum
so let us look at that
so now scrum is a framework that enables
teams to work together
means collaboration is very important
while we become agile
so with scrum team one can
look i mean see and experience
so learning from experiences happens so
those are captured
self-organize working on problems so
they work together they discuss
brainstorm reflect on their victories
means
any achievements has to be celebrated
acknowledged quick queens
recognized and their losses to improve
so wherever the things doesn't go good
necessary corrections has to be done i
think scrum approach would help in terms
of doing it quicker better
then some of the benefits using scrum
would look like steam can provide
project deliverables and in an efficient
manner
so in time
we are completing all the features and
functionality so the entire model the
methodology what is there which helps in
accomplishing those
then further time and money are used
efficiently
so
time is very important
giving results in the mentioned schedule
is very important
ensuring results are coming up
effectively is important efficiently the
performance of that products
now since we are creating those small
piece
working piece in every iterations
so that experience of using that would
also be there and quick feedbacks will
come back
so that time and money is saved
and we are doing in time
so projects are divided into
smaller units called sprint so the
iterations what are speaking about the
quick iterations of activities which
happens uh during the adoption of scrum
when organization adopt the scrum
methodology
so it is called a sprint it's a time box
write relations which will have a set of
subset of product backlog taken as a
sprint backlog and those users stories
and epics are delivered as part of that
sprint and then those are reviewed on a
daily basis as part of daily scrum
meeting and also
we have other meetings which will happen
when we go and look at
methodology how this happens i think
we'll get better visibility
work best for fast moving projects
now whenever we need to respond quickly
whenever we want to move faster now
remember when we say moving faster means
it doesn't mean that we can allow any
defects to happen we can ignore
something we cannot do that we need to
ensure everything is taken care at the
same time all those results what are
created has to be acknowledged
right confirmed yes it is defect free so
all those which is supposed to be
addressed are taken care and things are
moving faster and better and the results
are according to
what was actually expressed as a
requirement it is fulfilling those
then scrum meetings provide the team
great visibility
since there is a daily scrum meeting
which keeps happening people speaks
about what they have done from the
previous daily scram what is that they
have accepted they will complete and
what is complete is everything is
complete or something is pending if it
is pending why is that pending and what
is that you are going to do further
before the next daily scrum meeting
so these are discussed understood so
that there is a quick 15 minutes meeting
which gives the insight and further
wherever there is a dependency
deviations which occurs
further maybe scrum master sit with them
separately to understand that in detail
so daily scrum meetings give the quick
insights
so that it increases the visibility what
is happening on ground
constantly involves feedback from
clients and customers as i mentioned
earlier while discussing about agile
active involvement of a customer is very
essential so customer should to give the
feedbacks whenever that working piece of
the application or a product is given so
only then whether the product or that
module what is created is having that
features and functionality which helps
in providing necessary requirement
fulfillment is that happening or not
then making changes based on feedback
are very easy because everyone is
informed and they are aware of what is
being changed and what needs to be
changed
then individual efforts of the team
members are given focus
yes individual efforts is essential
at the same time each team member cross
skills we call it a self-organizing team
as i was mentioning earlier so each team
member will have a different different
skills different different capabilities
and also cross-skilling within the team
is encouraged so that the ownership on
individuals deliverables and team as a
whole working together to deliver some
features functionality can also be
accomplished
right
then scrum team involves product owner
scrum
master and then scrum team so each of
these are different roles having their
own objectives to accomplish with the
specific directions
and each of this cannot be merged like
for example
the roles and responsibilities of
product owner cannot be given to single
individual who is a scrum master so both
the roles cannot be given a single
individual because it conflicts the
objectives of both the rules so thinking
about putting this one of the team
member becoming scrum master product
owner thinking in that angle is also
something which is which will not work
which will not give the required results
so now what are these roles what are the
responsibilities where is the focus of
each of the roles
so let us discuss on that now when it
comes to product owner so the product
owner is primarily responsible for
maximizing the roi by determining the
product features prioritizing it into a
list what needs to be focused on for the
next print and constantly reprioritizing
and refining it
so the key points what we need to see
here is
so one is determining the product
features
maximizing the roi the second one
and then re-prioritizing and refining
the product backlog
now why is that needs to be done so
maximizing roi in the sense obviously
product owner should closely work with
the business
and have an insight towards what is that
business required what is that customer
require how it helps customer to
accomplish that result so that it helps
the justifying that investment what
they're doing with the products features
and functionalities
then uh speaking about reprioritizing
and refining it it depends on what
features needs to be delivered in what
order so there is already an order which
is defined
so
based on the change scenario you can
reorder it and product owner has that
ownership and responsibilities so
the entire focus is on ensuring the
right product backlog prioritizing it
and also adding that user stories and
effects into
product backlog
depending on what makes sense to the
business
so the scrum master the next role helps
teams learn and apply scrum to obtain
business value
means
scrum master closely works with the team
so he or she helps remove impediments
what is impediments
something which stops
to move forward something which doesn't
allow
to deliver things the way it is required
something which stops
right so that needs to be eliminated
that needs to be understood what are the
impediments so when we say impediments
what are the impediments we can think of
the skills and capabilities of the team
that is one thing maybe the testing
environment may be a process
so anything comes as a bottleneck or
impediments which stops things to move
smoothly forward
so scrub master should work on it
identify that and support team or guide
team to overcome those
so protects them from interfaces that
helps the team to adopt agile practices
so encouraging team to adopt agile
practices and ensuring they demonstrate
it and provides the required value
as its move forwards so since scrum
master focuses one side in terms of
making scrum team to work whereas
product owner is looking at the entire
product backlog and working more closely
with the business so they need to have a
good handshake to ensure things go well
but these two roles cannot be merged
because since it has two different
angles and two different dynamics so
spending time accomplishing both the
things may become very challenging and
conflicting
and the prioritizing will also be
difficult
then scrum team is a collection of all
the individuals who work together to
deliver the requirements of the
stakeholders so self-organizing team
what i was mentioning what we were
discussing earlier
so these teams comes together each of
the team member will have various
different capabilities
so they contribute at the individual
level and as a team has a whole
complement or contribute towards
ultimate output and outcome and value
what they need to create
and this team should have a
clear understanding about the
deliverable what is being done
so is that deliverable what features and
functionality what they're thinking is
that going to create that value
ultimately what is need to be achieved
the requirements fulfillment which is
which needs to be happen to the
customers so they need to have that
understanding the direction should be
clear to the team
so there are certain artifacts to look
at when it comes to scrum so let us look
at that
so now we speak about the artifacts
which are the components of the scrum
process
that can improve transparency and
understanding of the work so there are
three artifacts mainly which we call it
as a product backlog
sprint backlog
then product increment
so let us see what is this one by one
so when i say product backlog so it
consists of list of new features
changes to be made to existing features
the bug fixes
changes to the infrastructure and
several other activities that the team
needs to deliver to ensure a particular
outcome so this list show product
backlogs becomes with
required features and functionalities
what needs to be delivered so
the prioritization of this has to happen
in what order what needs to be delivered
so
the product backlog is the full list
which needs to be delivered as part of
this project and as the project
progresses
a lot of new backlog item would be added
to the product backlog
as the dynamics of the particular
scenarios keeps changing so keeps adding
reprioritizing additional items to the
backlogs are added depending on what are
those dynamics
so further looking at a sprint backlog
so
sprint refers to that short period of
iterations
right so which team aims to get a given
amount of work done so it helps teams
deliver working software in a frequent
manner
so sprint could be between one to four
weeks long depending on what is that
deliverable is
so sprint backlog is a subset of product
backlogs so that prioritize item what is
taken into sprint which is a time boxed
iterations
the sprint backlog contains the task the
team aims to complete to satisfy the
sprint goal so what is that sprint goal
so each of those iterations the time box
iterations will have a specific
objective to accomplish
so the sprint goal is the objective
decided for the sprint as an outcome of
negotiation between the product owner
and the team so what can be delivered
how long it takes to deliver
so when it has to be delivered the
target may be given by product owner but
is it possible feasible to complete it
there is some negotiation which happens
there
so they decide they agree yes we can do
it we cannot do it if at all we can do
it what is that it takes in terms of
effort time and cost everything is
decided discussed
so that objective of that particular
iterations is agreed upon
so once it is agreed i think team should
first identify the tasks from the
product backlog that need to be
delivered to achieve the goal
so these stars are then added to split
backlog so there should be an agreement
between both
and once it is added once it is agreed
as part of that sprint
the deliverable the output of the sprint
would be
the one which needs to be completed as
part of it the objective is the goal the
results which is specific working
software
then product increment so this refers to
the combination of all product backlog
tasks completed in the sprint and the
value of the increment of previous
sprints
now when we speak about lean lean speaks
about elimination of waste it speaks
about value streams
now in each of these prints as we have a
working software being delivered now
each of these piece should keep
complementing to the what is the one
which is already delivered and what is
being delivered in future
so keeping that in mind every
deliverable will be implemented or
configured in such a way that there is
no specific bottlenecks there is no
specific constraints which arises so
this needs to be kept in mind which
requires the entire visibility into what
is that ultimate objective we are going
to accomplish
so in this product increment all those
combination of the product backlogs task
which is being done should keep this in
mind team should be very clear about it
so i in the first sprint i delivered
something in the sprint two i delivered
something but i cannot integrate them
they cannot work together
it will lead into the further issues and
then complications that should not
happen
so when we say agile it's about moving
faster fine so responding to change fine
but that should not lead towards further
complexity it should make things
simpler smoother so scrum is stressing
on that part
so an increment refers to
inspectable usable work done at the end
of the sprint it represents a step
towards overall goal or vision of the
project as i was mentioning
then the outcome should be
in usable condition even if the product
owner doesn't decide to release it
so it should be an usable condition so
two things we speak about so one is uh
release other one is deployment
now people usually get confused between
release and deployment so release about
this part what we're speaking about
product is usable
so it is released product is usable but
only after deployment user will have an
access to use it
so that is the difference release makes
a product usable whereas deployment
makes it available to the user to use so
this difference people should know so
release doesn't mean that it is already
available for user to use
so this understanding of the difference
should also be there so that
one can understand what it means by
release as well and what it means by
deployment that's why when we speak
about devops we keep speaking about
cicd we speak about continuous
integration
continuous
delivery and continuous deployment so in
continuous delivery you're speaking
about release basically so once it is
released it becomes usable so once it is
deployed it is available for user to use
and that's about the scrum artifacts
now let us look at uh scrum framework
how that scrum framework looks like in
entirety so what are the components
comes into picture already we spoke
about the scrum approach itself what it
is
now we spoke about understanding
artifacts then we spoke about roles in
scrum the activities for each of the
roles we understood
now where do we see all of this when we
look at a scrum framework so that
picture let us see
so when we say scrum framework already
we spoke about the product backlog
we can see that it is in the left side
in the beginning
we have a sprint planning so we spoke
about sprint the time box iterations and
from the product backlog
the items which is moving towards
sprint to a specific sprint what needs
to be delivered which become sprint
backlog now the backlog items are taken
and scrum team work on it
and does this daily scrum meeting and
once the deliverables of that particular
sprint happens then there is a review on
it
then the increment is delivered and at
the same time that retrospective what
was planned versus what is delivered
that is checked if you look at from
sprint review so you have a
retrospective to check
what is planned versus what is being
delivered at the same time the review
points will come and get updated to
product backlog as well to the product
owner so product owner should be aware
what is delivered what is spending to be
delivered and that increment is
further delivered so these increments
what is delivered to production what is
deployed in the production should have
values
that integration which happens
both all the increments coming together
to provide that fulfillment of the
requirement as well as creating that
value what is required
so product backlog is the first step of
scrum framework is a set of list of
tasks to have successfully achieved the
goals of the stakeholders we discussed
that while discussing on product backlog
so further sprint planning happens
where
the team determines the tasks from the
product catalog
they will work on and aim to deliver
during the sprint now this is negotiated
understood agreed and then most towards
spring to get delivered
then sprint backlog are the tasks
discussed during the sprint planning
means
the previous step
and also do the script planning and then
add it to the sprint backlog once it
goes to the sprint backlog as part of
the time-boxed iteration sprint the
deliverables should happen
now scrum team the scrum team which is
actually self-organizing team as we
mentioned maybe five to ten nine members
of team
working on the task in the sprint
backlog and they will also have a daily
scrums where the team also
discusses for 15 minutes
on the events where the team member
synchronizes activities and plan what
they aim to achieve in next 24 hours
what is accomplished against what is
discussed in previous daily scrum and
then
if at all any further discussions need
to be done in the correction of those
that can be taken as a separate meeting
not as part of the daily scrum so
generally daily scrum meeting would be
15 minutes it should not go more than
that it's an indicative time so quicker
updates to understand what is happening
then uh the sprint review happens
where once the sprint is complete so
sprint review happens which involves the
team the scrum master and product owner
and stakeholders to understand what is
being agreed upon and what is being
delivered so reviewed is that fulfilled
in the entirety that is discussed
and then during this meeting the team
shows what they accomplished during the
sprint it allows time to ask questions
make observations
give feedback and provide
suggestions right
then the product owner also presents the
product backlogs talk to the
stakeholders
to get feedback for upcoming sprints and
about things related to the backlog
now this one sprint is complete for the
next print what should be the
prioritization
so the product owner has to speak with
the stakeholders so that there is a good
understanding good handshake that what
needs to be delivered and what is the
priority in the given list
then sprint retrospective happens
so after this print review
sprint retrospective happens so during
this meeting what went well like past
mistakes potential issues
what are the new ways to handle them
which are required to be done correctly
in the next
iterations or next prints needs to be
identified
data from found from here are
incorporated when planning the new
sprint so it's works like a lessons
learned what went well
what did not go well what is that we did
for those what did not go well so what
is that learning we have in this
iterations so how can we ensure that in
the upcoming iterations the same
mistakes are will not repeat
so those can be
discussed documented and then consider
while moving to the next spring
then the increment is a workable output
which is given to the stakeholders so
this is where the user actually sees the
workable piece working item and then
they give necessary feedback as well on
the particular
application piece or software
piece
then there is something called scrum
board which is used during this flow of
scrum
right from product backlash to the
creation of that increment
so let us look at what is a scrum board
which is used during the scrum practice
so scrum board is a physical or virtual
tool that helps team to visualize items
in the sprint back clock so it helps in
tracking what is being delivered what is
in progress and what needs to be
delivered further
so it shows all action items during the
daily scrum
helping keeping the team focused on
tasks that need to be completion and the
priorities of those
the scrum board is usually present in a
place that's accessible to all team
members it is a visual board right and
can be physical whiteboard and stickers
or virtual software tools which can be
used and displayed on the screen
so the scrum board is divided into
different slots like to do
in progress and done
so when new sprints are started the
existing board is reset and new scrum
board is created so since it is visual
system i think it is taking the thought
from kanban so visual system always
works effective because
the moment i know i see something is
put
against my name that i need to complete
this it's quite obvious to me that i
will put efforts to complete it so it's
a conscious effort what i will put it
works on my consciousness so something
which is not visible to me it is that
out of sight is out of mind so i will
not work on it so i may there is a
tendency to forget
so if i see it regularly if i have that
feeling or that vibes which comes to
every individual such someone is
everyone is having a visibility to it
something is pending against me
so i'm answerable that consciously that
comes to the mind and people start
working on it and closing of that will
happen quickly
so everything is visible there is
nothing hidden
so look at the scenario so when once it
is explained i think
it's okay even though we messed up this
time we'll incorporate scrum into our
products
i am sure we will do a good job next
time
but keep in mind whenever change comes
it doesn't mean that i need to go and do
crumb practice never get into that
decision
understand what is the nature of change
what is that speed how quickly you may
require to do the change and what is the
impact of the change
how often this changes may come up you
may know this from the lessons learned
with the adopted practice and
methodologies
and then decide is the existing model or
existing practice whatever we are doing
is it okay or should we really need to
go and uh by have a buying from the
scrum and entirely we organize ourselves
to have a scrum approach so it is always
advisable to go for a scrum approach
whenever there is a dynamics of quickly
moving from left to right from product
backlog 2 that increment what needs to
be created so accomplishing that speed
and involving the consumers regularly if
it is feasible so consumer and
stakeholders may say they cannot involve
then you becoming a gel will not make
sense because they are not even giving
the feedbacks so active involvement of
the
team
the scrum master the product owner the
business the stakeholders the consumers
very very important if they don't
involve
so the deliverables cannot happen the
wait is required so active involvement
active collaboration of every
stakeholders are essential there should
be collaboration and communication the
effective collaboration and
communication which needs to be
happening
the product team has taken up a new
project called weather master
the team is planning to move to scrum
methodology and this is an outline of
its first scrum meeting
time box to 15 minutes rick is the scrum
master of this meeting where the team
members discuss what they did yesterday
their plans for today and the
impediments they faced all team members
are standing up including todd who's
joined the meeting via video chat
rick holds the meeting near a scrum
board
angela the product owner is absent
rick reiterates that all discussions
would be parked until after the scrum
meeting and encourages this team to keep
the meeting short
people can chime in to resolve obstacles
hi team
welcome to the daily stand-up meeting
for the product team on project weather
master
we are in sprint one and today is the
second day
as we are planning to transition to
scrum methodology i hope you will find
this daily stand-up meeting helpful
in this meeting you will provide
information about what you did yesterday
what you plan to do today
and what challenges you faced
i think everyone's here let's start
i don't see angela shouldn't she be here
i did add angela as an optional attendee
to this meeting and since she hasn't
showed up we don't have to wait for her
susan
scrum doesn't provide a specific yes or
no about the product owner's
participation in the daily scrum
the po's primary role is to provide
direction and clarify requirements and
priorities
since we don't always discuss those in
detail at this meeting the po is not
required to be here
if the pos want to attend they are
generally in listen only mode for the
duration of the meeting
they can use the information gathered
during the meeting for separate offline
conversations
what about todd he works from his home
office right
todd will be a part of the meeting
through video chat it is important that
we include every team member in the
meeting
hi todd how are you
i'm fine thanks am i audible
yes todd team let's all stand up for the
meeting
why don't you go first aaron
yesterday i was working on creating the
mock objects to mask the database calls
from the unit tests
the difficulty with this approach is
that our server side logic is so
dependent on the metadata that writing a
true mock is a mammoth exercise
there are decisions that are taken
during run time based on the data some
of the stored procedure calls are also
made based on the values returned
through inline queries that are also
embedded in the code
i was debugging the code until about 9
pm
but for the life of me i couldn't figure
this out
aaron could we request you to be concise
when you provide an update if you think
some of the details you described might
be interesting to others why don't you
write a wiki page on it and share the
link
so getting back to your update did you
finish the task yesterday
no it turned out to be much more complex
than i had imagined i'll continue to
work on it today and see if i can figure
out an xml structure to mock the schema
and hard code some return values but i
am really stuck as far as the inline
queries are concerned
i know what you're talking about
there is a reason why the inline queries
are there in the code
this is mainly for performance reasons
when the overheads of making a procedure
called based on a metadata value and
then processing the sorry for the
interruption again guys
this is a really great conversation may
i suggest we write this issue in the
parking lot
i'm not sure what you mean by that rick
let me explain what aaron just brought
up is a blocking issue
team members should bring these up
during the daily scrum so that everybody
knows that one of the team members is
stuck
however the daily scrum is not
necessarily the meeting where solutions
to every obstacle can or should be found
it looks like mary knows a thing or two
about the issue that aaron has brought
up
let's jot this down as a parking lot
topic
this means the team can have offline
conversations after the daily scrum to
track it down
i'm also going to make a note that will
track the impediment aaron faced daily
until it is removed you should let me
know if i can help in any way right
aaron is there anything else you would
like to say no i am done thanks
yesterday i worked on developing the
wizards for bulk order creation i'm
almost done today i need to write code
to handle some of the exception
scenarios before i can get them over to
susan for testing that's it for me i
guess
did you forget to mention any
impediments
not really an impediment at present but
i would like to mention that my computer
probably needs to be upgraded with more
ram it has been slow for the past few
weeks
okay i wrote up some scenarios to test
the bulk order wizard i'm looking to get
my hands on the code as soon as mary is
done
today i'm also hoping to complete the
company order testing that has been
pending for a while i'm okay for the
moment but i do have one question
shouldn't we all be updating the task
board as we speak
we could it is up to you guys if you
think you want to do this during the
meeting if you ask my opinion we should
update the board as soon as we are ready
to move the tasks and not wait for the
meeting
this will ensure that the board is
always up to date and also that we use
the meeting time to focus on the
conversations
that's a great point rick i can't see
the board very well from here anyway so
maybe we should find a way to create an
electronic version of it too at some
point
great point todd why don't you go next
with your updates
all right hey rick would you like to
know about my work on the advertising
module first or the integration server
whatever the team decides is fine with
me
remember this is really your meeting and
i'm only here to facilitate and ensure
we get the most out of this meeting
all right then i guess i'll start with
the integration server i would like to
inform everybody that i managed to set
up the integration server that we can
use as a sandbox to test the code before
checking it in source control i'll send
everybody a link with some instructions
and credentials
i have also started looking at the
stories for the advertising module it
looks like there are a lot of open
statements in the stories that i don't
really understand i guess i should have
been paying more attention during the
sprint planning i really need to have a
conversation with angela about this that
is my main impediment right now i sent
her an email but haven't received a
response yet
i don't have anything new to add today
i'm almost through with setting up our
project on the freeware tool that i
downloaded yesterday i'll show you guys
a demo in the meeting i set up later
today
i'll try to chase down some of these
parking lot items
anything else before we close the
meeting
all right that's it for today have a
great day
do you have a moment to chat about the
inline queries real quick
the purpose of a scrum meeting is to
keep the team members updated and
resolve any impediments
it's an ideal way to kick start the day
on a positive note the scrum master
reinforces the sense of the
self-managing team facilitates
communication between team members
brings the team's focus back to what's
important and supports improvement
in this session we will be talking about
agile project management and several
other things related to it before we
begin let's have a look at all the
topics we will be covering today first
we will see the basics of agile project
management then we will check the
relevance and principles of agile
project management we will then see
necessary steps to implement agile
methodology along with that we shall
also see different frameworks involved
in the process and finally we shall see
some companies that use agile project
management so without any further ado
let's get started with what is agile
project management agile project
management as the name suggests is a
flexible approach to building a project
in agile project management the project
is broken down into several stages of
sprints agile does not work on the
principle of delivering the final
product at the end of the project it
works on delivering sections of a
project or many projects the process of
project management in the case of agile
is agile based so there won't be any
central control of project manager as it
was there in the traditional way of
working before we move forward let's
have a look at the agile development
cycle agile methodologies consist of
several small cycles or sprints at the
end of each stage we get a mini project
there's a product backlog that explains
new features changes in the existing
features and several other improvements
in the project then we have a sprint
backlog which has a list of tasks that
are to be completed during each sprint
the sprint consists of planning
designing execution testing and
deployment stages and at the end of each
sprint a mini project is delivered with
every sprint new features are added to
the product which plays a significant
role in the overall project growth after
all the sprints and early validation in
the development the final deliverable
has a fewer chances of failure let's now
have a look at some reasons why
industries have started moving towards
agile project management the first
reason is high product quality when we
talk about higher product quality we
refer to the build of the product as per
stakeholders demands testing is
performed at short intervals of time
wherever needed to ensure high quality
of the product then another reason is
customer satisfaction whatever is done
in the project is known by the customer
the deliveries don't take longer
durations as they used to take in the
case of traditional ways the changes may
be provided by the customer in the
execution phase of the project third
reason is reduced risk since the project
is divided into sprints so if the risk
affects one sprint it doesn't mean whole
of the project will be at risk the
process of risk analysis continues to
take place with all the other processes
another significant reason for agile
project management is better and faster
return on investment the project is now
developed in several sprints and each
sprint has its own version therefore the
project becomes market ready after a few
sprints only since the projects can now
be released with ease and in shorter
duration this helps the organization to
stay ahead in competition with respect
to other organizations which have still
not moved to agile methodology now we
shall check the principles of agile
project management there are 10
principles for successful agile project
management the first principle is the
satisfaction of the customer by
delivering the project fast and with
least number of errors the next
principle refers to decreasing the
amount of time between the phase of
planning and delivery the third
principle states that the team of
managers and developers work together
and increase the productivity of their
work the next principle states that the
changes requested by the stakeholders
can be taken into consideration and
worked upon during the development phase
as well the fifth principle pays
attention to the factor of coordination
among the team members then the sixth
principle refers to the process of
monitoring and tracking the progress of
the project at the end of each sprint
and making amendments wherever needed
moving on the next principle states that
there must be a feeling of trust and
support towards the team to complete the
project's objectives the next principle
emphasizes on face-to-face conversations
with the development team the
face-to-face conversation helps in both
solving problems and easy knowledge
sharing then the nine principle
emphasizes on finding solutions and
maximizing the amount of work done with
simplicity this ensures timely
completion of tasks by all the team
members
the last principle states that scrum
tools like monday.com or zoho sprints
must be used to simplify the complicated
codes which further helps in saving time
we shall now see the steps in agile
project management the goal of agile
methodology is to produce shorter
development life cycles and more
frequent product releases than
traditional waterfall project management
so we will now check six steps in agile
project methodology the first step in
the process is project planning project
planning includes feasibility study
development of scope breaking the
project into executable tasks or sprints
and then estimating the amount of time
needed to complete those sprints the
second step is the step of roadmap
creation a roadmap is a plan of action
that shows how a project shall evolve
over time a list of all the features
that the final product should have is
created and the steps to achieve those
features are taken the next important
step is release planning since we are
doing the project keeping in mind the
agile project methodology the project
will complete in sprints that means
there will be the release of features at
the end of each cycle and unlike the
traditional waterfall model the
development cycles will be smaller the
fourth step in agile project management
is sprint planning the sprints are made
keeping in mind what all is to be
accomplished in that particular step at
the beginning of each sprint the goal of
that sprint is decided and steps to
achieve that goal are taken the next
step in the process emphasizes on daily
meetings there are short meetings every
day to discuss if the team was able to
finish the task for each sprint and
check if there are any amendments that
are required each team member talks
about what they achieved in the last
print and what are they going to work on
in the next print the last step is the
step of sprint review and retrospective
there are two meetings after each sprint
first meeting is for the sprint review
this meeting is with the stakeholders to
show them the finished product this
helps both sides to build a relationship
and discuss if there are any issues in
the end product the second meeting is
for having a sprint retrospective this
meeting involves the stakeholders to
discuss what went well and what went
wrong during the sprint sprint
retrospective takes place after the
sprint review and before the next print
planning now when we know the steps
needed for agile project methodology we
must understand some agile project
management frameworks there are several
frameworks available today here we will
be discussing some of the most popular
frameworks the first framework we will
discuss is the kanban framework kanban
framework is a well-known framework for
implementing agile software development
in the case of kanban framework work
items are represented on the kanban
board which helps all the team members
to see the state of every piece of work
at any time kanban board not only helps
in visualizing the work but also
optimizing the workflow among the team
the next framework we will discuss today
is the scrum framework scrum framework
is a popular framework for managing
complex knowledge work like in the field
of research and advanced technologies
scrum is a simple framework that helps
team work together and learn through
their experiences gained while working
on a problem the third framework we will
see today is the hybrid framework the
hybrid framework is a combination of
agile methodology and non-agile
methodology in the case of a hybrid
framework planning is done using the
traditional way of project management
while the execution and delivery is done
using the agile methodology since the
hybrid is a combination of the two it
handles the requirement changes and
delivers the product in different stages
the fourth and the last framework we
will see is the lean framework the lean
framework works on the principle of
providing maximum customer value and
creating zero waste it focuses on
optimizing the flow of products all
through the value stream this helps in
eliminating waste all through the
process and create processes that
requires less human efforts this also
simplifies the process of information
management and makes it more accurate
finally let's have a look at some
companies that have opted for agile
project management today around 22
percent of the organizations worldwide
have all their teams working on the
principle of agile project methodology
let's have a look at some of the most
prominent companies in the world that
use agile project management in the list
we have ibm cisco atnt microsoft philips
and samsung
so as part of this tutorial we are going
to look at what are user stories
advantages of user stories
investing in user stories how to write
user stories three c's of user stories
life cycle of user stories
then user story map and its advantages
now let us look at a typical scenario of
an organization
where the need of user stories would
come in so looking at this scenario so
an organization would have a scenario
where the existing products are sold
very well in the market
and they may think about introducing new
product or they may think about
introducing a new feature or
functionality to the existing product
so the scenario what we are considering
is it says our previous products sold
really well in the market now let's
think about new products so we'll need
to make sure we can understand the
requirements and fulfill the
requirements now how do you do this so
how are you going to understand the
consumer requirements user requirements
and how is that going to help the user
to
accomplish the requirement and fulfill
the need whatever it's required to be
fulfilled so user story helps one who
understand user stories would look at
the perspective of the users and these
user stories provides those insight
towards
what user would exist
so as we go through we will understand
in the perspective of the users the
requirements and how user stories helps
in terms of fulfilling those
requirements this requires certain
amount of visualization let us see what
it is so what are user stories
user stories are an agile software
development project management tool
that provides users with simple natural
language explanations of one or more
features written from the
end users perspectives
so for a given product we may have many
end users
so we may develop an application within
an organization and use that application
for an organization that is one scenario
second scenario is we create a product
we sell it and employees of our customer
organization will become users of those
products these are the two scenarios
so having these scenarios what kind of
product it is what is the objective of
this product which is going to fulfill
so let me assume an hr application which
is used for
submission of claims from the employees
so what is that requirement so this
application should accept the claims
submission from the employees of the
organization and then that needs to be
processed and the claims needs to be
cleared now what will happen now the
user community if you visualize there is
an user as an employee of an
organization who submit claims so there
is an user in the finance perspective
who is going to deposit the money
similarly there is an user who is going
to approve
so many such user interfaces we will see
the existence of the roles of users we
will see who would be using these
particular applications
so in their perspective there should be
an interface provided there should be
some privileges provided through which
they would do their transactions and
activities when we write the user
stories we don't write them in detail
so a user story doesn't go in detail it
just mentions how a certain type of work
will bring value to end user
so what is this role specific end user
would be
doing at that particular role in this
particular product what is the
transactions involved so the end user in
this case could mean external end user
or even internal customer or colleagues
within the organization so looking at
these points if i look at the same
application hr claim processing
application who are these internal users
the employees of organization so who are
these external maybe the people who sold
this particular application to our
organization so they have installed it
they manage it there is an
administration role for this particular
product that is a role
similarly
another set of
internal users maybe someone who is like
from finance from hr
so in each of these roles perspective
this particular product should provide
the interface and then there should be a
transaction in their perspective which
is very important so user story should
explain this in very brief so that it
helps in terms of visualizing what kind
of interface has to be provided and why
would this particular role use it that
is very important
so user stories also form the building
block of agile frameworks like epics and
initiatives so what is this epics what
is this initiatives let us look at it
now epics refers to the group of user
stories where the large amount of work
broken down into user stories so many
user stories together forms epics which
will provide certain insight towards how
these user stories are connected with
each other
so similarly initiative refers to
combination of multiple epics forming
that initiatives so which is very
essential to group so managing
perspective it will become easy and also
looking at the objective what is that
particular group of user stories group
of epics are going to accomplish so user
stories can also help ensuring that team
work to goals of the organization
through epics and initiatives it should
be looking at that objective exactly
what is the directions we are getting
into and how these combination of user
stories so as an employee i'm submitting
my claims so what is that required in
that user's perspective there should be
a story so i as a finance person i'm
going to clear these claims i'm going to
pay the money deposit the money so that
is that particular role needs certain
interfaces and that visualization
requires how this interactions happens
so user story should help in terms of
understanding those so the requirements
for making user story a reality are
added later after discussing with the
team so i we made an user story we
created an user story
it doesn't end there so there needs to
be discussion which happens further to
decide yes it is a valid user story
so this will also helps in terms of
prioritization which needs to be taken
up first so user stories are recorded on
post it notes or an index card or a
project management software
and this would help in terms of
prioritization or for tracking as well
so what is the advantages of user
stories
so advantages of user story involves it
helps in delivering high quality content
because what is required to be
accomplished in the user perspective
that will be very clear
eases collaboration with team members
because finalization on the user stories
and understanding of the user
requirements would happen after
discussing with the team members each
one would give their own
viewpoints and
prioritization of particular user story
or keeping a specific user story or not
considering that user story would be
based on
the feedback which team provides this
cannot happen in terms of having team
members together and speaking about it
helps understanding users better so user
roles are discussed users requirement is
discussed and what is that go they are
going to accomplish through this user uh
interface that is also discussed so user
role is understood user requirement is
clearly understood by writing an user
story
this will also help in improving
transparency because since the
collaboration is happening since the
user story is not just taken just like
that the discussion happens
and that will have an interaction and
collaboration so definitely improves
transparency
so now it reduces risks
so when i say risk it's obviously
uncertainty
so it reduces risk because the clarity
one would have about the requirement of
users so accordingly
the features functionality of the
product are defined so that they can
fulfill those user requirements then
supports iterative developments as i
mentioned earlier the collaboration the
transparency everyone working together
and in the agile perspective users
stories epics and initiatives gets into
the specific iterations only after this
discussion with the team members and
after prioritizing it so the user story
will be there in the product backlogs
which will be prioritized based on that
particular scenario of requirement in
agile scenario so as when we say giant
it's quite obvious we need to be
flexible to the changing scenarios so
since we're working together and when we
go for an iterative mode of approach
it's quite obvious we're going for it to
get adopting to the changing scenario so
that we can select that particular
features functionality by pulling that
particular epic or user story as a
priority in the given list so that
prioritization making will also become
easier focuses on local communications
means lot of interactions happens while
discussing on user stories so since
people are doing it locally so there is
some personal touch also established
could collaboration can get established
so it was user story also provides that
visibility because of that
people working together in a
collaborative manner
invest in user stories so what is invest
so investing in user stories so what
does that mean
so it is a concept that helps creating
meaningful user stories so it stands for
independent
negotiable
valuable
esteemable
sized appropriately testable
so when i say independent
so whenever we write the user story
that should be self-contained if at all
possible
to avoid dependencies on other user
stories so it should be independent of
one another so that each of them can
be developed and delivered separately
so negotiable so when we say negotiable
user stories can always be changed or
re-returned
so at any given point in time so we
should be able to do that modifications
required so that should support the
flexibility associated with the agile
methodologies so since requirements
often evolve changes and this changes
comes for various different reasons so
how do we change this user stories or
modify this so that it can fit into the
requirement so that adaption can happen
to the changing requirements so story
should be discussable and should be open
for negotiation for any change scenarios
so next valuable
when i say valuable it's quite obvious
we're speaking about value what is being
created for the users or consumers
so a user story would represent
the goal or an objective an end user
who is going to look for means value is
always in the consumer's perspective so
now i created certain features
functionality is fine but did that
really create the value to the consumers
so the value realization plays an
important role so stories must ensure
there is a value being added to the
consumers and customers or users always
otherwise user story doesn't make any
sense so esteemable so when we say
estimable one should always be able to
estimate the size of the user story so
sometimes developers may not have the
experience required to size the
particular situations or need it for an
user story
reasons may be anything it may be not
having specific insight towards it or
don't know how to estimate there may be
someone specific who needs to understand
that scenarios and then come and discuss
reasons may be anything so stories if
they cannot estimate then it will become
difficult in terms of
handling it better so it should give
some visualization so it should be
estimable and can be divided into tasks
so now small
means sized appropriately
so user story should not be very big or
should not be too small
and then
how do we decide on this size
so now when we say uh any user story
that can be completed by a developer in
single iterations
then
can we call it as two week
quite obviously that is again indicative
so user story should be subdivided into
two or more small stories into multiple
pieces multiple stories small small
stories so that it can be handled better
so story should not be too big and
should be completed within 40 hours or
three to four days these numbers are
indicative
so not necessarily you should be fixing
with this number so just an indicative
to show you that
what would be the focus when i say use
the story in what is that effort it
would take to accomplish that now
testable
so
when we say user story is testable
one has to ensure that development is
complete and has been done correctly so
means one once you create a user story
so that needs to be articulated in such
a way so that it becomes measurable when
i say testable obviously there should be
metrics a target metrics which can be
created which will help me to state yes
this particular requirement is
accomplished so they should have an
acceptance criteria that can be tested
to check if they fulfill the customer's
need so then how to write user story
this is very
important uh point to look at so how to
write the user story
so writing user stories comes up with a
specific template with a
simple language so what is it so now as
a role i want to
so that so you keep filling it
so typically role means what the
specific user role who would be using
that particular product and their
requirements which are being fulfilled
so that is the role the name of the role
we are going to put it here
so the role refers to an individual that
would be interfacing or interacting with
the system now uh one two when we say
one two the one or action which
represents the behavior of the systems
so what is that it's supposed to do
this action would be unique to each user
stories now so that this refers to the
benefits or results that non-functional
and external to the system as a result
what would happen
what is that we are trying to accomplish
out of it
so let us look at an example how does it
look like as a ceo i want to track my
subordinates progress to ensure
organizations goals are met similarly if
we take the reference to those examples
what we discussed earlier
like we took the example of hr portal so
claim processing requirement now this
can be same user story as an employee of
an organization what can i write
so as an employee of this organization
i want to submit my claims online
so that claim processing will become
smoother easier faster without any
errors so that can also be user story so
it gives certain visualization what kind
of users are there and what is that
they need so the moment you write the
user stories you should visualize that
rule it is very important so there is
three c's of user stories which we call
it as
card
then
conversation and then confirmation
so when we say card card provides a
written description of the user story so
what do i mean by written description of
the user story
so same thing the user story what we
just saw is an example
so that can be written on a card so this
will help in planning and estimating so
what and that will also gives that
visualization of users and their
requirement so that that can be
articulated further and also estimated
so that it can
looked in the perspective of invest what
is invest what we discussed so it is
independent it is negotiable it is
valuable
it is estimable
it is
sized appropriately means it should not
be too big too small the examples what
we saw was appropriate
and testable so now when we see
this particular user story is it
fulfilling
all those points what we discussed in
invest that is very important now this
card whatever the description is
provided should elaborate on that very
clearly so then further what happens
conversation
after the user store is written in a
card and given and it is shared with
every individuals who is participating
in that conversation
so then there will be discussion so
conversation represents discussion
between users
team
product owners so this helps in terms of
whatever the user story is written is it
making sense is it in line with the
user's expectation and at the same time
whatever the understanding we have maybe
as a product owner or the team member a
developer is my understanding correct
then user perspective so whatever the
user story is written is that user story
is speaking about the requirement which
needs to be fulfilled as they require so
this helps to build a shared
understanding between all those
individuals so that there is no
confusion further
so once people converse together once
the stakeholders converse together
then you will confirm confirmation
so this represents the condition that
need to be satisfied to ensure
that the story meets all requirements so
you are confirming so all the
stakeholders are agreeing to that
so firstly to summarize this three c's
refers to card conversation confirmation
card provides the user stories which
actually represents as we took an
example which will capture that so that
it also fulfills the thought of invest
then
conversation is required to understand
what is this user story speaking about
is that a real requirement so
confirmation further in terms of
confirmation from users as well as all
the stakeholders before you go and
develop or execute that so what is
lifecycle of user story so when we say
life cycle so we may require to
understand a life cycle starts when you
conceptualize
when you visualize when you say this is
what we are required to accomplish there
should be consuming someone should
consume that idea
so it may be related to a problem it may
be related to a specific product for an
opportunity what is seen so whatsoever
the reason it is there is a scenario
where something is conceived trigger may
be a problem trigger may be some issues
what is being faced trigger may be an
opportunity what is seen
so then the
initiative the trigger which actually
pushed towards
creation of the requirements and user
stories so the life cycle of user story
starts from there so how does it go
so it involves
right from the point pending to to do
then discussion then developing
conforming and then finished so when i
say pending i'm basically saying user
stories in their most basic forms where
they are created after communicating
with the user and the project team
these acts as the reminder for further
discussion so first level of
understanding on user stories in the
basic form so which will help in terms
of further
discussion and taking a call on that so
will there be a possibility that this
user stories will be modified as we
progress answer is yes and no both so it
may be modified but discussion is
further which goes on uh from this basic
understanding of that particular user
story
so further discussion is to elaborate on
that make sense out of it and confirm so
then after discussion with the
stakeholders users stories that need to
be addressed are
decided and put into sprints
so in between
the point where we set pending to to do
so in between this there is a lot of
discussion so where decision is
happening here so decided and put into
sprints means there is a prioritization
also which is happening
so now discussion at this stage user
confirms users confirms the requirement
and acceptance criterias
so acceptance criterias helps in terms
of
once you test that particular user story
after executing you will check based on
these acceptance criteria so that you
can conclude the requirement is
fulfilled
the end users are shown a preview of
upcoming features
so that they understand yes this is what
we were expecting they can provide their
feedback necessary feedbacks or insights
whatever is required to be provided so
then
once the discussion is complete the team
would be able to design and implement
features to fulfill user requirements so
once user concludes yes this is what we
were expecting and there is a sign of
during the discussion
then features are developed and
implemented so that it can goes to that
product which can be used so then
after developing conforming
so the end user confirms there is a
story features are confirmed to testing
environments alpha versions and
acceptance criterias are looked at
before
saying yes it is confirmed user is
accepting so that will happen as part of
confirming means that features or
functionality what was written in user
story so that specific users are using
it and concluding our acknowledging yes
this is fulfilling our requirement and
this is according to the acceptance
criteria
what we discussed and agreed so that is
very important so we write a user story
fine but users are not agreeing to it
that is not a good scenario to be with
user should accept and confirm then
finished so the user store is completed
at this stage for new requirements or
new features a new user story must be
created any new features or new
functionality i am required to add to
this particular product then i would
write another user story and the same
life cycle starts continues and this is
not an ending thing so as i keep
modifying the features
as i add new features add a as i look at
improving the performances so i keep
writing the user stories now one
question keeps coming to me so we write
a user story while fulfilling the
requirements fine as a specific user i
want this easy to narrate that so how
are we going to look at a scenario where
there is an improvement of something so
whenever we are going to discuss about
improvement of something it is quite
obvious we need to look at it what is
that improvement user is looking at now
when i am
submitting a particular
request or accessing something it is
taking some time means there is some
delay now user experience can be
enhanced by reducing that particular
time that is improvement as a user the
user story basic user story doesn't
change but in the performance
perspective you may require to visualize
that so problem statement has to come in
accordingly user story has to be
articulated then once the user store is
written it is required to put there is a
story
mapping
so user story mapping represents
and arranges user stories
that help with understanding the
system's functionalities
the system's backlog
planning releases and providing value to
the customers
so typically this involves arranging or
organizing user stories based on the
priority along the horizontal axis so i
will horizontally when you
move
so i will say which one is the priority
which user stories are priority first
thing which i need to focus on so
vertical arrangements represents how in
a given specific user story how the
activities perspective task perspective
sub task perspective
further down how it gets elaborated to
improving the levels how it goes forward
so now let us look at
an user story mapping with an example of
let me see net banking services
provided by a bank for account holders
when i say net banking service it is
quite obvious it is also has to be
provided through having a product
which banking application would use
so but here we need to visualize the
user's journey while accessing the net
banking portal
viewing the account details paying bills
like utility bills
doing a lot of transactions within that
particular portal that banking access
the moment they do
like generating statements
or transferring money to one of the
benefit beneficiaries
etc so all these transactions what is
being done
so in this user story map let us see how
does it look like so few activities are
considered here
like
logging into the account means net
banking portal will come in
then one would input their credentials
and then they log in
now that journey of the users in a
specific activity what they do is
visualized
now login to account in the sense
obviously one has to go to that portal
so go to login page then enter
credentials login id and password so
once that login id and password is
entered obviously there is a process
engine which runs behind to provide the
necessary access now if that credentials
are not
uh working or if i don't remember it
reset password is an option immediately
now as i go through further from this
sub task in all the particular uh
columns which i have given here as you
go through this as i deep dive into it
further it goes on so until the person
gets an access to the account and then
start doing the transactions it goes up
to that level so i can keep writing the
subtask further so manage account so you
would go to account page once you access
it
then you'll select the specific account
because you may have many different
account types which is there with the
bank you may be having one or many so in
the scenario you have more than one
obviously you will select that account
and account details will be displayed to
you so this user will not do but user
will get that so we are visualizing that
and further after account details are
displayed what
user would do then further you would
keep visualizing that
so some of the transaction like
generating statement transferring money
so even for that the steps are written
so going to statement page
then selecting the account for which you
need a statement then selecting the
period from uh when to when the
statement one is requiring and then uh
further clicking on it and downloading
that particular statement
or choosing an options mentioning that
uh i need this an email or i need an
hard copy of this so similarly
transferring money so you will go to
that specific wage where you need to
transfer the money so you may have the
beneficiary there in the list already
added
if you have added earlier or newly
you're adding a beneficiary
so there are various types of transfers
like so international transfer you will
have local domestic transfer will have
within a bank
accounts being within the same bank bank
a two consumers so from me if i'm a
consumer transferring money to another
consumer of the same bank and vice versa
that is one of the options
second is a bank consumer having and
transferring your money to some other
bank account of someone else that is
another scenario or
transferring money for my own account in
another bank so various different
scenarios you come across so then
limitation or depending on what kind of
beneficiaries are these what is the
limitations and how are you going to
authenticate them so the moment i
visualize a specific transaction and
activities of user stories what are the
things an user can do then i can keep
writing the mapping this to each of
those flow
and see how the flow happens so this
flow helps me to bring in all those
features and functionality and also
prioritizing them so can i say the
beneficiary option would be the basic
thing which uh consumer would give i
think initially if i go back when
actually net banking features were
provided by the bank the basic thing was
just viewing the account that was the
given statement download was given
otherwise uh there was no opportunity to
transfer money there was no opportunity
to do something beyond that so now as we
see today the lot of flexibility has
brought in with lot of new features
functionalities in the net banking or
mobile banking options so they evolve so
as they evolve it is quite obvious we
may require to keep adding those
features functionality by writing the
user stories this is how the enhancement
happens so overall if you look at user
story mapping helps in terms of
understanding not just the user story of
one transaction
associated transaction in the user story
what happens throughout the journey that
will help
so this will also support to understand
and visualize
what needs to be created to ultimately
give that access to the user so the
end-to-end flow should be visualized and
also needs to be prioritization and has
to be looked at as well now what are the
advantages of user story mapping
so the advantages wise
helps with prioritizing work
as explained in an example
similarly the focus is on user value the
moment i click on webpage
www.abcbank.com
now the bank page will come i will have
an interface of login i will go and
click on login now from the point i open
a browser and input that url and then
click on login and login page comes in
how long it takes so there are many
things which is involved the browser
things are involved the system from
which the person is accessing is
involved so removing that part so
thinking that both of them working well
and what should be the response from the
server where this particular website is
hosted that experience needs to be
looked at so that's how you look at a
user value in the transaction now once i
put a credentials now how quickly the
authentication happens
what are the checks the bank portal does
to ensure that the person who is logging
in is is a genuine user is it just a
password
is there any captcha codes
is there any otp sent or is there any
secret code the person has to put in
so likewise many things are involved
while giving that experience to the user
so and today's user if you just put in
various different checks points they
understand because they are well
educated so white all those things like
captcha or otp scenario scheming so
these are came in because more and more
informed the people has become
then their ability to hack also improve
so more and more levels
added to ensure that only that genuine
user will enter the user account
similarly when you visualize any product
and user journey in the user's interest
what are the things which is going to
create value that needs to be understood
so only that experience will help for
the user to realize the benefit then
roadblocks are highlighted so as we
visualize this journey so this will tell
me so what would stop me to move forward
is there any concerns is there any
constraints
like for example if you want to activate
a beneficiary but for some limited
period you can only send the limited
amount of money why is that done by
chance if the beneficiary is added by
that individual who is not a genuine
user so we are actually holding it right
so by the time that freezing time
whatever is given so by the time the
message goes to the actual consumer
telling that there is a user activated
like this and if at all if it is not a
genuine user obviously the person can
call to the bank saying that this is not
the
beneficiary which i have added there's
something which is not correct so they
are giving that space so how did they
visualize this has to be done so as we
looked at the journey of adding a
beneficiary it's quite obvious when
beneficiary is added if by chance
someone who is not authorized adds it
so who is going to this benefit
obviously user will be disbenefited so
that blocks that constraints are
visualized
similarly in making or creating that
features functionality what should be
the basic features or in the product
should be ready only then i can add this
feature even that will be visible right
so roadblocks will be highlighted and
that those will be made visible
so that easy for you to move forward
prioritizing and ensuring that it goes
in the
flow required to accomplish that value
so then ensuring team unity because
everyone will have a visualization user
stories and mapping reads a lot of
discussion brings the people to have a
common understanding
so obviously that unity the
collaboration would come in
focus on constant improvement
so improvement is the key whatever you
do you you are just adopted a waterfall
methodology you have just adopted an
agile you write user stories you raise
your peaks you write bring in that
various different methods to do
something whatever you do whether it is
product or a service or a process
or a specific
transactions task reports whatever we
make
so all that should help in terms of
identifying the opportunities for
improvement and making that improvements
that is very important
today as all of us know agile has become
a well-known development methodology and
the approach of choice for many
development teams
especially those trying to create an
environment of continuous delivery
when we think of agile
we often think of high levels of
collaboration and flexibility
as well as iterative environment in
which requirements evolve alongside the
changing needs
so as a result
we also tend to conceptualize agile as
an approach
that helps development teams across
various industries delivered new
features faster but how do we get there
what does history of agile entire
and how can knowing the history of agile
helpers better understand the
methodology and its positive impact on
today's development world
let us look at it
so now
historically if you see
the waterfall approach was fine it was
delivering the required value
but it required teams to stick to the
requirements and scope of work set out
at the very beginning of the project
and not make any changes or additions
along the way as the project progresses
and following that fixed plan could
prove trouble sometimes
comparing to the scenarios which we had
earlier which is today the trouble is
more
challenges more so reason being
waterfall methodology prioritized
bringing a complete product to market
meaning it could take years before teams
finished the project in hand
the scenarios of change
delay in responding to problem
resolution
meeting changing market requirements
were challenging which led to
introduction of agile methodologies
so the various development methods like
scrum
rapid application development extreme
programming dsdm
feature driven development and pragmatic
program
were introduced
so it all started
early i think in 2001 it was introduced
however it all started in the spring of
2000
when a group of 17 software developers
in oregon to discuss
how they could speed up development
in order to bring new software to market
faster
so they recognized two key opportunities
that achieving this goal would make
possible so reducing the time to the
benefits for those users in order to
resolve the product market
fit and development problems
secondly
getting feedback from users quickly to
confirm the usefulness of new software
and continue to improve on it
accordingly
so further these group of 17 developers
met again at a ski resort in snowbird
utah us
so they created popularly known as agile
manifesto so which laid out four key
values
so which says individuals and
interactions or processes and tools
working software over comprehensive
documentation
customer collaboration or contract
negotiation
responding to change or following the
plan are valued more
now
further between the time when it was
introduced till today
agile has become popular
and adoption of that has increased
reason being the flexibility the agile
brought into the system
so several organizations across the
world started using it
but what happened further
so agile gave the result but there was a
challenge
so there were some issues that agile
face to handle widespread usage
that is mainly whenever there is a
scalability requirement
so what is that scalability challenges
it is quite obvious
how can an implementation of fragile for
large and more complex project
and how hard the process to scale age at
so this was not clear
the very reason
the challenge which come across which
the practitioners actually faced was
one is lack of experience with agile
methodologies
little understanding of frameworks
methods and how to implement them
next
large scale coordination
so when i say a specific project a small
project it was easy implementation of
agile and then going forward all these
frameworks what i mentioned earlier it
was easy but the moment you want to do
scaling to the bigger organization the
complex environment
the coordination collaboration
dependency management between
usually distributed teams geographically
distributed teams was challenging
and thirdly
having a clear understanding of what
needs to be completed
in the sprints and what the bigger
picture is
so fourth
aligning the entire organization and
managing commitments
so definitely organization
required alignment the products or
services which are being produced by the
project needs an alignment
so the need of alignment was basically
to ensure the organization gets the
value out of whatever they have invested
so fifth unrealistic expectation with
respect to speed of delivery
so unable to respond to this particular
scenario so that
organization can able to respond quickly
so it was not happening so time to
benefits i i was mentioning about
so generally earlier we used to speak
about time to market but today it has
been replaced by time to benefits how
quickly the value of that particular
product or services introduced to the
market is realized by the users that is
very important
so the framework of scaling agile there
are various different frameworks so some
of the most effective ways to scale
agile
would be
large scale scrum which is called sls
scaled agile framework
disciplined agile scrum at scale
nexus scrum the spotify model
so when i say less the large scale scrum
it is a way of scaling agile and scaling
scrum to large and
big product development groups
it has been used since 2005 in different
software and hardware products in
industries such as banking and
so when it comes to skilled agile
framework
so it is a set of organizations and
workflow patterns intended to guide
enterprise in scaling lean and agile
practices
so it is made freely available by scaled
agile link which retains the copyrights
and registered trademarks
so the disciplined agile delivery which
is also called as dad is a software
development portion of the disciplined
agile toolkit
so dad enables teams to make simplified
process decisions
around incremental and iterative
solution delivery so that builds on many
practices
by
advocates of agile software development
including scrum agile modeling liens of
development and others
so scrum at scale
so scrum originally if you look at
outline in the scrum guide is a
framework for developing delivering and
sustaining complex products by a single
team
so since its inceptions its usage was
extended to the
creation of products processes services
and systems
that require the efforts of multiple
teams whereas scrum at scale was created
to efficiently coordinate this new
ecosystem of teams
it achieves this goal through setting up
a minimum viable bureaucracy
via scale free architecture
now coming to next one the nexus scrum
so this consists of multiple cross
functional scrum team
working together to deliver a
potentially releasable
integrated increment at least
by the end of each print
based on dependencies
the teams may self-organize and select
the most appropriate members to do
specific work
so lastly the spotify model which is
basically people-driven autonomous
framework for scaling agile while
emphasizing the importance of culture
and network
this methodology uses squads tribes
chapters guilds
the foundation which is called which
acts like scrum team
so further let us look at the our focus
area of this particular video which is
basically what is scaled agile framework
so scaled agile framework as i mentioned
earlier
consists of collection of principles
best practices and processes
that would enable large organizations to
adopt agile methodologies
so it would help them deliver products
and services of the highest quality
faster
so safe is best suited for complex
projects that involves several large
teams at the projects program and
portfolio levels
the current version of safe is version 5
which has seven core competencies based
on which it can help organizations the
large organization is specific
so safe has certain core values
which are basically
alignment
built in quality
transparency
and program execution
so when i say alignment
so i was mentioning about aligning with
business requirement business strategies
so it is needed to keep pace with fast
changing
disruptive competitive forces and
geographically distributed teams
while empowered agile teams are good
even great but the responsibility for
strategy and alignment
cannot rest with the combined opinions
of the teams no matter how good they are
instead
alignment must rely on enterprises
business objective
so it also need to require
to keep up with the change
the competitions and then the dynamics
across in the environment where
organization is doing their business
so next is built-in quality
so built-in quality is basically to
ensure that every element and every
increment of the solutions
reflect quality standards throughout the
development life cycle
so quality is not added later
building quality is prerequisite
of lean and flow without it the
organization will likely operate with
large batches of unverified unvalidated
work which leads to
the product or services which is not
okay and also that would lead towards
excessive rework which is not good
and slower velocities
which is not allow the organization to
respond quickly to the dynamics of the
market
so third one is transparency so
transparency which basically need to
enable
teams to rely on each other there should
be trust which needs to be built
so based on which high performance can
happen
so wherever the trust exists
so when the business and development can
confidently rely on
each other to act with integrity
particularly in times of responding
quickly or to work order a solution for
resolving something which is actually
not allowing things to move forward
so without trust no one can build high
performance teams and programs
so the confidence needed to make
reasonable commitments is very very
essential
so fourth is program execution
so safe focuses on working systems and
business outcomes
which mainly for example for teams to
execute and continuously deliver value
safe places an intense focus on working
systems and business outcomes
so this is because while many
enterprises start the transformation
with individual agile teams
they often become frustrated as when
those teams struggle to deliver more
substantial amount of solution value
reliability and efficiency
so
delivering solutions with better value
reliability and efficiency effectiveness
is very very essential and here we're
speaking about ensuring the scalability
to the bigger organization so program
management plays a very important role
so that requires lot of communication
collaboration
so without a better execution of that
without handling it better things cannot
go the way it is required
so various competencies safe recommends
so safe competencies involves
team and technical agility
agile product delivery
enterprises solution delivery
lean portfolio management
organizational agility
continuous learning culture
and then lean agile leadership
so when i say
p1 technical agility
so agile teams are high performing and
cross-functional
business solutions are built by business
and technical teams
delighting customers with high quality
output so this requires an able team
which understand agile frameworks which
follows it which complies with it and
also technically sound
so agile product delivery
which actually refers to the scenario
where the customer is at the center of
organization's product strategy so
development is based on cadence and
releases on demand
exploring integrity deploying and
innovating continuously
then enterprise solution delivery
so building big system with the help of
lean
coordinating and aligning the entire
supply chain
evolving the live system continuously
requires to ensure the visibility of
entire enterprises and providing
solution accordingly
lean portfolio management which
basically focuses on aligning the
strategy
funding and execution
optimizing operations across the
portfolio
decentralized decision making powered by
lightweight governance
then organizational agility
a lean agile mindset is created across
the enterprise it is very essential for
example i am working in a project i have
an attrition if hr does not understand
my project dynamics
and if they are not agile
me as a project organization becoming a
gel will not help similarly the one the
procurement similarly the processes
so very essential for all the
organization units to become agile so
that business
operations are able to complement
contribute that speed or the change what
is required
so opportunities and threats are
addressed quickly so risks are
identified
and addressed quickly so they are worked
on it so risk management can become
easier with the involvement of right
stakeholders
continuous learning culture so in this
scenario everyone learns and grows
together
exploration creativity are a very
important part of organization where
they should bring innovation
creation
execution maybe i think i come across
certain terms like intelligent risk
taking
so
learning through failures
failure should lead towards enquiry not
towards blaming so these are all the
things which are more and more discussed
when we want to make an organization a
learning organization
the continuous improvement of solutions
services and processes is everyone's
responsibility
then lean agile leadership
so by modeling desired behaviors
inspiring others
aligning words actions and mindset to
lean agile principles and values
lead change and guide others so this
requires a lot of accountability and
ensuring the correct information well
informed individuals to take forward
things
now how does safe work
so safe
considering those competencies what we
looked at the seven competencies so let
us see what happens in each of the
competences how does safe work using
these competencies
so firstly let us look at team and
technical agility
which basically
involves an agile team of 5-11 members
which helps defining build test and
deploy products
so this is done by dividing the task
into small easier to manage time boxed
iterations
right
then
chrome team led by the scrum master and
supported by product owner plan and then
deliver the product in increments
so further after delivery they have a
retrospective to determine how the
iterations went
and how it can be improved
this is incorporated into next
iterations planning phase
so the method used here could be scrum
or kanban so both are popular the
combination of this can be used
so scrum basically helps in
ensuring that things moves in iterations
and everything is visible and delivered
whereas kanban supports in terms of
making it more visible and able to
manage it better
so agile product delivery so a large
organization usually consists of several
agile teams each led by their respective
scrum masters
so these teams together represent agile
release range also called as art
so they usually involve 50 to 125 people
so
art are cross-functional and involve
everyone who understand customer needs
and can help with building and
delivering the solution required
so art uses an agile delivery practices
like the one used by the teams
to deliver value to the customers
so it uses time box iterations called
program increments or pis
which usually involves four to five
iterations
all the teams they get together to plan
their work during pi planning events so
they should work together they should
have full visibility while doing it
so three major components which are
required when we do agile product
delivery
is release drain engineer
then project management and then system
architect
so release train engineer represents the
coach of the art facilitated the pi
planning process
the project management provides the
vision for the project
and backlog of the tasks
system architect provides architectural
guidance for the process
and then
the teams
then make plans regarding what they
would be able to
deliver
so the program board is also drawn up to
determine dependencies between the teams
which also goes through program
iterations the pis as i mentioned
earlier
then after every iterations the art
shows the integrated output to all teams
through a system demo
so after the pi is complete
all team get together to retrospect
event called the inspect and adapt
events
so further a continuous delivery
pipeline is set up based on the art
devos practices are also used to ensure
values available on demand i think the
term devops is becoming more and more
popular today which actually
providing that visibility
need for collaboration need for cultural
transformation
so which helps in terms of bringing that
agility across the organization as well
as learning organization so one of the
principles of devops itself says
continuous learning
there should be continuous
experimentation and learning risk taking
intelligence risk taking and also we
come across speaking the concepts like
semian army concept like introducing
failures into existing systems and learn
what can fail and what is the solution
for it
and that can help in terms of becoming
more resilient and reliable system
so devops has become popular
and adoption of that discussion on that
is
become more common across the
organizations
so next enterprise solution delivery
so enterprise solution delivery let us
look at a scenarios where a single art
may not be able to deliver an
appropriate solution
a solution train which coordinates
multiple arts and suppliers would be
able to provide solutions in large and
complex scenarios so meaning
consideration of enterprise has a whole
seeing end-to-end organization entire
visibility
so basically what is that we are trying
to achieve so alignment we discussed
about which requires the objective of
organization because organization is
investing so whatever we do at various
different levels should complement to
each other rather than contradicting so
that complementing thought or
complementing visibility can happen only
when someone has a bigger visibility
enterprise
world while outlook
then the three major components that are
required in enterprise solution delivery
would be solution management solutions
architect and solution train engineer
the solution management holds content
authority over what needs to be built
solution architect handles the
architecture across the arts
solution train engineer enables coaching
and facilitating of solution stream
events
so next is lean portfolio management
so lean portfolio management provides
ways of creating and combining strategic
themes and portfolio vision
this enables solution development to be
aligned with enterprise strategy
so the moment i say lean firstly we
should keep in mind that
it's about creating value to the
stakeholders that is first thing second
thing is elimination of waste
now when i link this to strategy
when a link towards the organization's
directions what it sets and while going
in the directions i should ensure
no defects
are actually moved downstream or are
eliminated when it goes to downstream
so customers should see the value which
is very important and identification of
all the contributions of waste has to be
done and eliminated
so this ensures there is a value in
organizations value stream which also
ensures that these value streams
remain funded so funding plays a very
important role
so next is organizational agility
so when i say organizational agility
it should ensure the organizations
various business units in the
organizations
should be with that dynamics of agility
which organization is going through
which organization is moving through as
i mentioned earlier if you have a
project where you have you have adopted
agile methodologies it's quite obvious
for your pace for your flexibility for
your speed other business units which
are working with you to support you
should also complement to that
they cannot become slower they cannot
have their own pace of doing things like
in your project you have a procurement
you have a recruitment
you have some claims to be cleared from
hr
maybe you're dependent on certain tools
and environments now if these are not
agile if these are not responding in the
same flexibility or same speed what the
agile project team requires then
obviously things will not flow further
now when i say agile obviously we
introduce products or services quickly
to the environment now someone needs to
manage we have operations
now can operations manage the products
or services which they are not aware of
now even there the agility is required
as i keep introducing the new products
or services to the environment
operations should also be well informed
and educated about it so that they can
monitor and manage them effectively and
efficiently
if they fail i think users will not have
a good experience your product or
services may have a great features
functionalities
but however if whenever there is a query
about that product features or
functionality
whenever there is an issue the incident
which user actually calls the first
point of contact for any users would be
the operations
the moment operations fails to respond
with the right clarifications or rights
resolution
quickly then obviously user experience
will result in not a good way i think
customer satisfaction or customer
delight will be at stake so an operation
should become a job
so rest of the business units which are
supporting like funding we spoke about
the funding is not done in agile way
obviously
the things cannot move smoother or
easier
so everything across organization should
become agile organizational agility has
to be ensured so enabling portfolio with
strategic agility making change in the
direction depending on the scenario
then encouraging the growth of
lean thinking people and agile teams
so people should be working towards
ensuring creating value always every
task every transaction is what they do
should be enabled through it
so they should also know
whatever we are doing how this
particular task or the work or the
results what i am creating
results in value addition or value
creation to the organization does it
really align to the organization's
requirement is it fulfilling maybe
customer as a stakeholder
or my own organization the business unit
which is actually investing on this
project so in that context or in that
perspective everyone should be aware of
that alignment the directions the vision
then focusing on value and helping with
organizing and reorganizing
building an environment for the flow of
value across the organization so
everyone should realize value so value
is what value can be defined in the
perspective of every individual's
background and every individual's
requirement because it's a perceived one
so there may be real thing what we have
created but perception is different
so the perceived versus what is actually
created
should be as closer as possible so zero
deviation is expectation but
difficult but however it should have a
tendency towards it it should actually
be very near to that perceived reality
but two things involved one is that i
create a features and functionality for
my product or services which fulfills
customer requirements
customer may not know not well educated
not aware of it and don't know how to
realize that value
how to know how these features and
functionalities can be used
so now if you educate that customer the
user how to use it what are the values
it can create and
do some
exercise in terms of educating training
coaching customer can visualize it and
just understand that that is one
possibility second thing is customer is
very mature and our product does not
have features and functionality required
so these are the two scenarios which
required lot of interactions and
engagement so that increasing in terms
of usage of products and services and
realizing those values
so this has to be encouraged more and
more
so further continuous learning culture
so when we say learning it's quite
obvious
organization should keep maturing
individuals in organization should keep
maturing in terms of capabilities in
terms of ability to do new things
innovate the knowledge the capability
skills competencies
so that can be possible only through
learning
so learning should be continuous
so this ensures an atmosphere of
innovation
and constant improvement until
organizations becomes a learning
organization
so meaning at every level each
individuals each professionals each
engineers each executives
invest their time in learning
they learn through what they are doing
they go through formal training
they bring in that formal training
learning into the actions here for their
they learn so continuous experimentation
creating an hypothesis working on those
hypotheses aligning that to the
requirement of organizations and seeing
how is it complementing to the
organization's requirement so seeing
through this are very essential so the
organization which is having the culture
of continuous learning can sustain and
grow
continually
there is no question of looking back
if organization has a scenario of not
learning
they will fade away they may fail to
exist so it is very much required to
understand the market dynamics
continuous learning there capabilities
and skill enhancement continuous
learning here innovations and making
things better continuous learning so
continuous learning helps organization
to
be there in the industry and continue
with the competition
so next is lean agile leadership
so it's quite obvious
leadership plays very important role
it's about guiding it's about owning
it's about showing directions
it's about ensuring everyone does the
task everybody is motivated
so the leaders must embody teach and
exhibit
lean and agile principles and values so
firstly they should understand what it
is they should be aware of it they
should have an
exposure to it they should have full
awareness of it as i was learning about
continuous learning culture in the
previous point so leaders should do that
first so only then i think the followers
will actually have learning adopted to
themselves and things move smoother and
better
and this should happen across the
organization
so
by doing this
it is quite obvious
organization can become better agile
organization is complemented to achieve
the objectives and goals what they
wanted to accomplish
and
there is a safe configurations which one
needs to ensure
which involves
essential safe
raj solution safe
portfolio safe and full safe
so when i say essential safe it acts as
the foundation for all safe
configurations
and is the easiest starting point for
implementation
so large solution safe it is used for
building large and complex solutions
whereas portfolio safe provides
principles and strategies that can
enable business agility in an enterprise
so when i say portfolio it should be
understood as a portfolio of an
organization as a whole
the service portfolio the product
portfolio the business portfolio
so understanding of that and
complementing to that is very essential
so full safe is a comprehensive
configuration that includes all
competencies and ensures business
agility
so advantages and disadvantages of safe
so advantages involves
enabling decentralized decision making
it eases collaboration across
cross-functional teams
it ensures decisions are made with
strategic objectives in mind
so disadvantages include additional
layers of oversight which makes it
resemble the waterfall approach
the top-down approach can limit
understanding of the software lifecycle
and cause bad planning so visibility
providing that visibility is very
essential
then larger planning cycles and roles
that are fixed in development cycles
in this session we will be learning
about the two most popular software
development lifecycle models
we will be understanding the contrast
between the agile model and the
waterfall model of software development
so without any further ado let's get
started now before having a look at the
differences in the two models it is
important to understand the basics of
software development lifecycle and the
need for it
as the name suggests software
development lifecycle is a process that
is used in any software industry to
design develop and test a software
the goal of the lifecycle is to meet the
quality standards of a software
a software is always made keeping in
mind the customer expectations time
deadlines and cost estimations
the framework is a collection of steps
in which different tasks are defined and
performed at every step
let's have a look at all the steps
involved in the process of software
development
software development lifecycle has six
different stages
the first stage is planning and
requirement analysis it is the most
important and fundamental stage in this
step the inputs are taken from everyone
involved in the process
this information is then used to plan
the basic project approach and to
conduct product feasibility study
this helps the project to excel in the
economical operational and technical
areas
then comes the second step that is the
defining phase or the requirement
defining phase
once the analysis of requirements is
done this step involves defining them
and getting them approved by the
customer
this is made possible through a document
called an srs or software requirement
specification document
this consists of all the product
requirements to be designed
and developed during the project
lifecycle
after the defining phase comes the
designing phase the srs that was made in
the last step is now used as a reference
to construct the project
on the basis of the srs a design
document specification or dds is
documented which helps in deciding the
designing approach of the project
the next step is the building or
development
as the name suggests the actual
development starts in this step
the code for the software is generated
as per the dds documented in the
previous stage
for the code the programming language is
chosen with respect to the type of
software being developed
after the development the step of
testing the product comes into the
picture
this stage refers to the stage where the
product defects are reported tracked
fixed and retested
this is done until the product reaches
the quality standards defined in the srs
the last phase is the deployment phase
after the testing is done and the
product is ready to be deployed it is
formally released in the market
the product may first be released in a
limited segment and tested in the real
business environment
then based on the feedback the product
may be released as it is or with some
applications in the market
now when we know the steps of the
software development lifecycle let's
have a look at the sdlc models
there are several software development
lifecycle models defined and designed
which are followed during the software
development process
these models may be referred to as
software development process models
every model has its own set of unique
steps to attain success
there are several sdlc models in the
market
here we will be discussing the two most
popular models
the waterfall model and the agile model
so let's begin with
what is waterfall methodology
the waterfall model or the waterfall
methodology was the first process model
to be introduced
it is a linear sequential lifecycle
model that is easy to understand and
operate
in the waterfall model each phase must
be completed before the next phase has
to begin
the next phase entirely depends on the
output or deliverables of the previous
phase
the entire process of software
development is divided into a sequence
of several phases
all the phases can be seen as a
waterfall flowing steadily downwards no
phase overlaps the other phase and
begins once the previous phase is
complete
the steps involved begin with gathering
of requirements and go up to the phase
of
maintenance let's have a look at all the
phases in detail
the first phase is the requirement
gathering phase
as the name implies all the possible
requirements of the project to be
developed are gathered in this phase and
documented in a requirement
specification document
then comes the system design phase the
requirements gathered in the previous
phase are studied in this phase and the
system design is prepared
the design helps in specifying all the
requirements and also helps in defining
the overall system architecture
after the design phase comes the
implementation phase
after the inputs in the system design
phase the system is developed in small
programs called units
these units are integrated in the
upcoming phase
here in this phase each unit is
developed and tested for its
functionality which is referred to as
unit testing
now comes the integration and testing
phase
all the units developed in the previous
phase are now integrated into a system
post integration the entire system is
tested for any faults or failures
after the testing phase comes the
deployment phase
once the entire testing is completed the
functional testing and the
non-functional testing the product is
deployed in the customer environment or
released into the market
now comes the last phase that is the
maintenance phase
the issues that come up in the client
environment are fixed in this phase then
to enhance the project some better
versions are released
maintenance is done to deliver these
changes in the customer environment
all these steps or phases are strictly
followed one after the other like a
waterfall
moving forth we know about the waterfall
model and its phases
so let's now see what is the agile
methodology
the agile methodology believes that
every project is different
and needs to be handled differently
and the existing methods need to be
tailored to best suit the project
requirements
the agile methodology promotes
continuous iteration of development and
testing all through the software
development lifecycle
the process looks forward to quick
delivery of all the functional
components involved in the project
in agile the tasks are divided into
small time frames to deliver specific
features for a release
these divisions are known as prints and
these sprints have their own set of
deliverables which are decided at the
beginning of each sprint
the work can be reviewed by the project
team and the customer with the help of
daily builds and sprint demos
demo working software is considered to
be the best means of communication with
the customers to understand the
requirements and not just depending on
documentation
one of the major focuses of the agile
methodology is on the customer
so the process involves the customer
throughout the project
as the requirements cannot be gathered
completely in the beginning of the
project due to various factors
continuous customer interaction is very
important to get proper product
requirements
then there are several phases involved
in the agile software development life
cycle beginning with the building of
concepts and going up to the retirement
process
the life cycle consists of five
different phases
let's have a look at all these phases in
detail
the first stage of the agile life cycle
is the initiation phase the initiation
phase or the inception phase is about
the finalization of project scope and
the return on investment
in this step the team members that will
be needed for the project are identified
then time constraint and other resources
required to complete the project are
also taken into consideration
the second stage in the life cycle is
the planning phase
in this phase the team gets together and
identifies exactly what they are looking
for they make a firm plan of how to make
the project a success
in this phase the risks are estimated
and the milestones are developed with an
initial release plan
after the planning phase comes the
development phase
once the requirements have been defined
based on the feedback from the product
owners and stakeholders the actual work
of development begins
agile product development delivers high
quality working products in incremental
phases or sprints
then comes the release phase
the product after being developed is now
deployed and starts getting used by the
end users
the stages now are closely monitored for
any errors defects or bugs that might
have been left in the testing part this
phase continues until the project is
fixed with all the bugs and is ready to
be retired
the last in the final stage is the
retirement phase this last phase marks
the deployment of a newer version of the
product in which all the bugs are fixed
there may be some minor changes of
software in the newer version
and the older version is no longer
supported
the product may also be retired if it is
not cost effective in the present
business scenario
now when we know the basics of the 2s
sdlc models and their life cycle phases
we shall differentiate between the
waterfall model and agile model
depending on different aspects in
software development
the first aspect we will see here is the
life cycle
in the case of agile methodology the
life cycle of the model is in a
continuous iterative format this helps
in developing and testing a project in
several iterations
whereas in the case of waterfall
methodology the life cycle is in a
linear sequential format where the
development steps are followed in the
form of a top down approach
the second difference we will see is on
the basis of rigidity
as we know agile model is a very
flexible way of building a software in
which the feedback of changes may be
accepted even after the development has
begun
whereas the waterfall model is least
flexible and the structure of the model
is rigidly followed while developing a
software
the second difference we will see is on
the basis of rigidity
as we know agile model is a very
flexible way of building a software in
which the feedback or changes may be
accepted even after the development has
begun
whereas the waterfall model is least
flexible and the structure of the model
is rigidly followed while developing a
software
then the next aspect we shall discuss is
collaboration
if we talk about the collaborative
nature of the model then agile model is
very collaborative in nature which
enables it to deliver a better output
and complete the project in a more
productive manner
whereas the waterfall model is not open
for collaborations
it does not allow the team to
collaborate and strictly follows the
sequence of steps
the next important aspect is the process
in the case of agile method the process
is divided into sprints
that have their own deadlines and
deliverables at the end
the waterfall model has a process of
software development that is broken down
into several phases that go as a top
down approach giving a deliverable at
the end
now after the process the aspect we will
consider is accepting changes
in the case of agile methodology the
changes can be accepted after the
initial planning is complete
whereas in the case of waterfall model
the development requirements cannot be
changed once the project development has
begun
the next important aspect in our list is
software development
if we consider the agile model the
process of software development is a
collection of many different projects as
the agile approach completes the project
in several sprints
whereas in the case of waterfall model
software development is completed as a
single project or deliverable
the next aspect we will discuss is
testing
in the case of agile methodology testing
is performed in the same step in which
programming or building of the software
is being performed
whereas in the waterfall model there is
a separate testing phase in which the
system is tested and this phase comes
after the build phase we often come
across the question which development
model to choose for software development
these contrast especially these last
three will help you understand which
model will be a better fit for your work
the next aspect we will see is focus
that means what the agile or waterfall
model exactly focuses on
so agile model focuses on customer
satisfaction
and performs the steps with their
respective inputs making the entire
process to be customer centric
whereas the waterfall model strictly
focuses on the steps in the process and
rigidly follows the sequence
it just focuses on completing the
project at the end of the sequential
process
whereas the waterfall model strictly
focuses on the steps in the process and
rigidly follows the sequence it just
focuses on completing the project or
software at the end of the sequential
process
now the next important factor is the
projects
that states which of the two models is a
better fit for what kind of projects
if we talk about the agile process it is
well suited for projects in which the
requirements may change
whereas if we consider the waterfall
process it is well suited for
well-defined projects in which all the
requirements are well stated and no
changes are expected
the last crucial contrasting factor is
the customer satisfaction
as we know agile model is customer
centric and hence involves the customer
at every step of the process takes their
input and implements them
whereas the waterfall model is an
internal process that does not involve
the customers and just strictly follows
the sequence of steps
let's talk about what agile is
agile is a very popular principle that
is used in software or project
management
the approach involves creating products
in an incremental manner from the start
of the project rather than delivering
all of it at once at the end of the
project
agile processes focus on frequent
inspection and adoption
on encouraging teamwork
self-organization
accountability and delivering high
quality software
the business approach is to align
development with the needs of the
customer and that of the organization
now like i mentioned earlier the agile
process delivers work in small usable
increments
for organizations to take advantage of
agile principles
they need to adhere to the values that
are mentioned in the agile manifesto
agile puts individuals and interactions
over process and tools
working products are more important than
comprehensive documentation
customer collaboration is much more
important than contract negotiation and
responding to changes holds more
significance over following a plan
with agile the clients in the project
team can have large amounts of
interaction
this helps them understand each other
better
clients have greater transparency to
every phase of the project
the output is delivered in a predictable
manner and sometimes can happen sooner
than expected
it provides high quality development
testing and collaboration due to the
project being broken down into smaller
units
and thanks to continuous evaluation of
requirements plans and results
teams can respond to change really fast
now let's talk about some agile
methodologies
let's have a look at each of them
first off xp
extreme programming or xp is a framework
with which teams can create high quality
software
it can also greatly help improve their
quality of life
it also involves the appropriate
engineering practices to enable software
development now it is applicable for
teams handling changing requirements
while working with smaller teams
handling risks due to new technologies
and much more
next up we have kanban
kanban is a visual system that can help
organizations visualize their workflow
to design
manage and to improve the flow of the
systems
now it's applicable in scenarios where
the work is unpredictable
it is also used for deploying work
quickly without having to wait for the
other components
next up we have lean
lean provides a set of tools and
services that focuses on identifying and
removing waste so that the speed of the
process development can be improved
with lean waste is minimized and value
to the customer is maximized
the principles of lean can be applied to
any sector which is liable to produce
waste
then we have scrum
so we'll be taking a look at scrum in a
little bit but basically scrum is a
framework that involves teams
establishing a hypothesis
then trying it out reflecting on their
experience and making corresponding
adjustments
and finally we have crystal
crystal is a software development
approach that puts people and
interactions over tools and processes
with crystal processes are streamlined
and optimization is improved
crystal is applicable in scenarios where
the focus is on the team communication
being strengthened
now let's have a look at what scrum is
scrum is a framework through which teams
can work together with the help of
sprints
sprints are events that are time boxed
and are usually of two to four weeks
length
scrum enables teams to learn from their
experiences
self-organize and work on their problems
reflect on their successes and losses
for improvement
the team's progress is measured with the
help of a 15-minute long daily meeting
called daily scrum
during this meeting team members talk
about what they plan to do on that day
what they did the previous day and what
roadblocks they were facing
with scrum teams can deliver their
projects in an efficient manner time and
money are used effectively
thanks to some meetings visibility is
improved and improvements can be made
thanks to constant feedback from clients
and customers and so much more
now let's have a look at how strum works
so here's the entire process
let's have a look at each component
firstly we have product backlog
first a list of all the tasks that need
to be completed is created
now this list is called the product
backlog
now completion of all these tasks
represent the successful completion of
the project
next we have sprint planning
here the team decides the different
tasks that they are going to work on
and focus on delivering them during the
upcoming sprint
then we have sprint backlog
now the tasks that were discussed in the
product backlog are then added to this
print backlog which is basically just
another smaller list which consists of
selected items from the product backlog
next up we have the scrum team
the scrum team is a collection of five
to nine people who are working on the
tasks mentioned in the sprint backlog
then we have the daily scrum
now this is a 15 minute long session
during which team members can
synchronize their activities
and determine what they did the previous
day what they plan to do on that day
and what roadblocks they were facing
next up sprint review
now after a sprint is complete a meeting
involving the scrum team scrum master
product owner and stakeholders take
place
during this meeting the team shows off
what they accomplished during the sprint
questions are asked observations are
made
feedback and suggestions are also
provided
now back to the product backlog
now the product backlog is presented to
the stakeholders
so that the product owner can get some
feedback for upcoming sprints
then there's also the sprint
retrospective
now during this meeting previous
mistakes are identified and new ways to
handle them are determined
the data that's obtained from this
meeting is also used while planning the
news trend
and finally we have increment
now in this stage a workable output is
provided to the stakeholders
and after this another sprint starts and
the whole process is repeated again
now let's talk about strum versus agile
firstly let's have a look at
methodologies
now agile is a set of principles that
are iterative and incremental
agile has a number of different
methodologies you can choose from
there's xp crystal kanban even scrum for
that matter
let's talk about scrum now
scrum is an implementation of the
concepts of agile so basically most of
the important components of agile can be
applied to scrum as well
it provides the customer with
incremental builds that are delivered to
the customer in the span of two to four
weeks
an organization can be agile
but not practice crowd
however an organization cannot practice
scrum without being agile
next up let's have a look at projects
agile is more suited towards projects
that have a small development team that
consists of experts whereas on the side
of scrum it's usually better suited for
projects that are subject to a large
amount of change and that will rapidly
next we have leadership
now for agile a project head takes care
of all the tasks and has a very
important role to play in the process of
a job
a project head represents the entire
team and is responsible for getting
issues resolved by assigning them to the
appropriate members of the team
in scrum there's no leader
there's a scrum master who can overall
guide the spring process but the team
addresses issues by themselves
it usually involves cross-functional and
self-organizing teams
next up we have flexibility
agile is relatively more rigid than
scrum and cannot handle changes with
these
it also requires a lot of upfront
development process and changes within
the organization
with scrum you can enable team delivery
agile requires frequent deliveries so
that they can get feedback from the end
user
this in turn will help make the product
better
the product is delivered as well as
updated on a regular basis
with scrum after a sprint feedback from
the client for a build is provided to
the team
scrum involves daily scrum meetings to
review and get feedback to determine the
next steps of the project
the next print is only planned by the
team after the current sprint is
complete
next we have collaboration
with agile collaboration involves
face-to-face interactions with team
members of other cross-functional teams
for scrum daily stand-up meetings take
place with specific roles like scrum
master product owner and the scrum team
and finally we have design
with agile the design as well as its
execution it's relatively simple
with scrum the design and its execution
can be innovative and experimental
so you might be wondering which one
should you choose
now among both these options there's one
thing that will remain common
agile
now what you can decide upon is which
agile methodology you will be choosing
is it lean is it kanvan or is it scrum
let's jump into scrum vs kanban
so before we dive into the differences
between scrum and kanban
let's have a look at what exactly scrum
is
scrum is a simple agile project
management framework that is used by
organizations to help teams collaborate
handle unpredictability and complex
projects or products while ensuring the
products delivered are of the highest
value
it describes a set of meetings tools and
roles that enable teams to work in sync
and help them structure themselves and
manage their work scrum is one of those
things that's really easy to understand
but very difficult to master
and although scrum is seen to be used
generally by software development teams
its principles and themes are pretty
universal and can be used with just
about all kinds of teamwork
with scrum teams are able to learn from
their experiences
what worked out what didn't and things
like that
they're also able to organize themselves
to handle their problems effectively and
basically improve themselves by
reflecting on them
so how does scrum work
here we have the first component
the product backlog
the product backlog consists of a list
of tasks that need to be completed so
that the goals of the stakeholders are
achieved
then the team decides what tasks from
the product backlog they want to take up
and deliver in a two to four week period
called sprint
hence the name sprint planning
next the tasks that were discussed in
the previous phase are added to the
sprint backlog
this is a set of tasks which will be
focused on in the ongoing sprint
following this the scrum team which is
usually 5 to 9 members strong will work
on these tasks
now they also have regular scrum
meetings where they talk about their
victories the issues they face and what
they plan to do in the next 24 hours
and then they have the sprint review
the sprint review is a meeting during
which the team shows what they
accomplished during the sprint
now during this time questions are asked
observations feedback and suggestions
are made
the product owner also gets feedback for
upcoming sprints from stakeholders
they also have a sprint retrospective
now during this session past mistakes
potential issues and new ways to handle
them are identified
data from here is incorporated into the
new sprint plan
the final step is increment
here a workable and usable output is
provided to the stakeholders
so now that we know how scrum works
let's have a look at kanban
kanban comes from the japanese word can
bam which literally means signboard
like scrum kanban is a popular agile
framework that is a visual system by
which the work can be managed with ease
as it progresses
kanban uses something known as the
kanban board to make these things
possible
with this you can easily identify
bottlenecks and then fix them cost
effectively at optimal speeds
the main focus with kanban is
transparency
since everything related to the tasks
are on the board
everyone can keep themselves updated
it also ensures the teams focus on their
current tasks until they're done
this limits the amount of work that's in
progress
so on the kanban board
work is divided into smaller more
manageable pieces
the work that's needed to be done is
written on a note or card and placed on
a board
columns on the board help represent
where each item is
with respect to the workflow
now let's have a look at what these are
in detail
let's find out how kanban works
now the board consists of three major
components
there's the to-do list which represents
items that need to be completed
the ongoing column which represents
items that are being currently worked on
and the completed or the done column now
these represent tasks or items that have
already been completed
now although this is a physical
representation of the board
several organizations use software
versions of the board that replaces the
sticky notes with cards that can be
moved from one column to another as work
progresses
at this point you guys must have
realized how similar these two
frameworks sound
so let's run through some more of their
similarities
let's find out how they are similar
firstly they both have principles of
lean and agile
which means reduction of waste and both
of them are time-boxed and iterative
approaches that enable product delivery
in an incremental manner
both these frameworks aim to reduce the
amount of work in progress
this forces the teams to ensure that
they focus on a smaller set of tasks
this also makes blockers and bottlenecks
a little more visible
in both cases the work is divided into
smaller more manageable units
both of these frameworks use bull
scheduling now this means that products
are only built based on demand rather
than forecasts
transparency plays a major role in both
these frameworks by helping them drive
process improvement
and in both cases the release plan is
continuously optimized and finally both
these methods aim to deliver releasable
software often and earlier than expected
now let's have a look at how these two
frameworks are different from one
another
firstly let's have a look at cadence
cadence refers to the amount of time in
a sprint or before a release
so when it comes to scrum the entire
project is divided into time constrained
iterations
that is into smaller manageable units
but when it comes to kanban it's even
driven
next criteria we're going to have a look
at
is release methodology
in scrum releases take place after each
sprint which usually takes two to four
weeks to complete
for kanban releases take place in the
form of continuous delivery
they happen in such a way that changes
like new features configuration changes
bug fixes and experiments get to the
users in a safe quick and sustainable
manner
next up let's have a look at how changes
are addressed in both these frameworks
in scrum no change can be made while
this print is in progress
once it's complete changes can be
considered in the sprint plan and then
added to the sprint backlog
with kanban changes can be made at any
time and incorporated into the workflow
now let's consider the metric that's
being measured
in scrum for planning and process
improvement velocity which is the
measure of the work that can be
completed by a team in a sprint is the
key metric
in kanban lead time is the key metric
this represents the period of time
between a new task's appearance in your
workflow and its final departure from
the system
next let's have a look at how teams work
in these frameworks
in scrum you need a cross-functional
team
to achieve your goals in a sprint
in kanban cross-functional teams are
optional but specialized themes that
focus on particular aspects of the
workflow are required
now let's talk about new additions
in scrum just like handling changes you
can't add any items between a sprint or
nitration
in kanban new items can be added to the
board as long as there's capacity
available for it
now let's have a look at the job roles
within these frameworks
scrum has three major job roles
product owner scrum master and scrum
team
with kanban you don't have any specific
job roles
now let's talk about representation
or moreover let's talk about how data
can be represented
with scrum the board needs to be reset
once a particular sprint is
complete
with kanban the board stays persistent
throughout the entirety of the project
and finally let's have a look at project
link
with scrum it's better suited for longer
projects
and with kanban projects that can be
completed in a shorter period of time
are better
so which one should you choose
now selecting from these two methods is
mainly based on the requirements of the
team
do you expect your project to be shorter
do you want to make changes at any time
you don't want to set up job specific
roles
then kanban is the framework for you
or do you want a long running project
with different job roles and involving
cross-functional teams
scrum is the answer for you
based on the differences we discussed on
the last topic you can make an informed
decision
now let's have a look at some of the
popular companies around the world
that employ both these frameworks
some of the companies that have
successfully implemented scrum are
facebook general electronics and adobe
companies that have implemented kanban
are siemens bbc and sap
today we will learn how to become a
certified scrum master so without
further ado let's get started so here we
have two people
let's call them jim and pam
here we see jim introducing himself to
pam and the team as their new scrum
master
pam is now expressing interest in
becoming a scrum master herself and is
asking for some guidance from jen
happy to help jim starts
first let's talk about scrum
what exactly is it
scrum is an extremely popular agile
framework which enables teams to work
together while working on a complex
project or a product scrum helps teams
to self-organize to learn from their
experiences and to reflect on their
victories and losses for improvement
although commonly used in software
development the concept of scrum can be
applied to any kind of team it's
basically a collection of meetings tools
and roles that help the team structure
and manage their work
let's talk about some advantages of
scrum
first of all it improves the quality of
product development
with scrum you are able to develop
complex products in less complicated
process
teams are able to constantly make
improvements to their product thanks to
the input and feedback from their
customers
next it provides faster delivery of
projects
now this can be an extension of previous
point
thanks to the real-time updates from
stakeholders or end users the team is
able to immediately address the changes
this enables the project to be delivered
at a faster pace
then scrum gives you a high return on
investment or roi
scrum enables you to deliver projects
but decrease time to market thanks to
the results being delivered early it
gives stakeholders to further reinvest
it also proves the worthiness of the
project to the stakeholders who are
interested
next scrum enables self-sufficiency
and creativity
it enables team members to be creative
with problem solving and to take a
hands-on approach to the project
and since decisions are taken by each
member of the team they make sure of
their own
self-sufficiency and finally it improves
customer satisfaction
thanks to the constant involvement with
each phase of the project with feedback
and interactions the final product is
more likely to be in a form that they'll
appreciate
next
let's talk about the role of a scrum
master
a scrum master is an individual who
promotes and supports the usage of scrum
practices in the team and the
organization scrum masters have a high
level view of the project and help team
members perform their tasks better
without having to deal with obstacles
and distractions
a scrum master helps the team understand
the theory rules and values of scrum
considering there are many moving parts
in a project the scrum master enables
the business the product owner the scrum
team and other individuals to work
together in harmony
now let us talk about the
responsibilities of a scrum master a
scrum master ensures that the product
owner and development team follow scrum
values principles and practices
this can help teamwork effectively and
provide high quality results the scrum
master also ensures the team's
productivity isn't affected by any
blockage
if the problem can be solved by the team
members on their own the scrum master
helps the scrum master accesses
different blockages and prioritizes
solving each one of them
the scrum master also protects the team
from any distraction and any external
interference to make sure that they are
able to deliver value at the end of each
and every sprint a scrum master ensures
that the team isn't involved in any
irrelevant discussions and focuses on
the sprint's requirements the scrum
master also has different roles to play
with specific components of the scrum
process like the product owner the scrum
team and the organization
now let's have a look on the scrum
masters responsibilities to the product
owner
the scrum master makes sure the goals
scope and product domain are understood
by everyone in the team the scrum master
needs to find a way to effectively
manage the product backlog
this helps the scrum team understand why
their product backlog needs to be clear
and concise the scrum master needs to
ensure the product backlog is arranged
properly and to facilitate scrum events
like sprint retrospectives sprint
planning sessions daily scrum events
now let's have a look at how a scrum
masters is responsible to the scrum team
to develop the team to self-organize and
to enable cross-functionality with teams
to help the team create products of high
value to remove roadblocks that the team
may encounter the scrum team needs to
facilitate scrum events like they are
required now moving ahead the scrum
master helps the organization to lead
and coach its adoption for scrum
the scrum master helps to plan the
implementation of scrum the scrum master
needs to help the employees as well as
stakeholders the scrum master helps to
understand how scrum helps to increase
the value produced and finally the scrum
master helps to make changes that
increase the scrum team's productivity
and more now let's talk about how can
you become a scrum master first you need
to have a strong understanding of scrum
and agile concepts as a scrum master you
need to ensure that your team follows
the principles of agile and scrum
you need to have a clear understanding
of different teams and phases within
scrum to ensure you can understand and
teach the usage of framework to the
organization properly in short having a
detailed understanding of the systems
and terminologies is mandatory a scrum
certification can also greatly help with
this
more on that in a little bit you need
fine-tuned organizational skills you
need to be able to structure the team
and plan out their actions to ensure
everything stays organized
and to make sure everything stays on
track you need the ability to plan
things out you should be able to ensure
that the team stays on schedule and all
the tasks are completed successfully you
could also use online project management
systems like monday.com nutcase and sam
9000 to keep things organized you need
to be familiar with the technology the
team uses you need to ensure that the
team is able to complete their project
in a timely manner this can be done if
you have an understanding of different
technical terms and processes that the
team is involved with
hence some technical familiarity and
training is really important
you also need to have the ability to
coach and teach the team to follow scrum
properly for teams that are new to the
scrum methodology your ability to teach
them the different concepts terms and
principles play a very important role in
the future success of the team
you need to be able to tell the team not
only what it needs to be done but also
how and why
you also need to be able to encourage
the team members to work together and
improve themselves you may also need to
work with individual team members to
maximize their potential you need to
have the ability to handle conflicts and
resolve them quickly
considering how teams are filled with
people with different personalities
ideas and working styles it is only
likely that they may clash with each
other every now and then
if disagreement cannot be handled among
themselves you need to be able to figure
things out if left unsolved this could
inhibit the entire team's progress
so you must be able to negotiate and
resolve the conflict in a way that
satisfies everyone
and finally you must be a servant leader
a servant leader puts the needs of the
team before their own and helps each
member to perform the best of their
capabilities
you need to be both a leader and the
team member
you need to be the part of your team
while making sure
they can successfully fulfill their
requirements
now let's talk about certifications to
become a scrum master at a certified one
at that one of the most important things
you can do is to get through the
certified scrum master test this test
tests your understanding of different
principles and processes that are the
part of scrum process
moreover to take this test you need to
have completed an in-person or an online
course taught by a certified scrum
trainer or certified agile coach you'll
also need to have at least 14 hours of
face-to-face interaction with the
aforementioned trainer or a coach let's
get to the exam
the exam is of 1r and it has 50
questions in it and you need to score at
least 37 to pass the exam
the exam costs around 29 to 30 dollars
and you have two attempts to clear after
90 days or two attempts you'll need to
pay 25 dollars to write the exam again
once you are certified you'll need to
re-certify yourself by taking an exam
again after two years
now let's talk about the salary of a
scrum master according to glassdoor the
united states of america a scrum master
earns approximately
97 000 u.s dollars per annum
meanwhile in india a scrum master can
earn up to 14 lakh rupees per annum
hyped up about becoming a scrum master
yet let me now tell you about how simply
learn can help simply learn offers the
certified scrum master certification
training course so in simply learn
certified scrum master certification we
will be providing you with scrum and
agile methodologies
importance of agile scrum lifecycle
scrum terminologies roles involved in
scrum and much more so take your first
step to getting certified and getting
ahead in your career by clicking on the
top right corner and enrolling with
simply learn so question number one
what is chrome
so scrum is a framework that enables
team to work together
so with scrum teams can learn from
experiences
self-organize working on problems
to reflect on their victories and their
losses to improve
so this is a simple framework which will
provide a better ability and methodology
one can able to handle it better
so scrum is very well defined
articulated and this provides a better
insights and capabilities building
access is very easier and roles are well
defined
so define the roles in scrum so what are
the typical roles we come across in
scrum
so one of the roles we come across is
product owner
so product owner is primarily
responsible for maximizing the roi by
determining the product features
prioritizing it into a list
what needs to be focused on for the next
print and constantly
reprioritizing and refining it
so what happens is whenever we may
require to deliver it is very important
for us to have the requirements clear
what requirement needs to be fulfilled
to fulfill the requirements the products
what is produced should have specific
features and functionalities
so product owner will have the list of
features and functionalities
which needs to be created
when product comes out as a result of a
project
so product owner owns this primary
responsible to ensure these list of
features are identified and those are
prioritized as required
so next role we can think of a scrum
master
who helps
teams learn and apply scrum to obtain
business value so scrum master helps
removing impediments impediment is
anything which can stop things to flow
smoothly
so protects them from interface and
helps the team to adopt agile practices
now scrum is one of the methodologies
for agile
approaches and practices now remember
the term agile itself is not a practice
it it refers to indicate that move
faster become flexible respond to change
be flexible
now scrum methodology especially scrum
master should understand this dynamics
and ensure the team understands this and
scrum master should guide the team to
adopt these methodologies and ensure the
results are accomplished accordingly
so next role is scrum team
so scrum team is a group of individuals
who work together to deliver the
requirements of the stakeholders
so scrum team is generally of the size
like five plus or minus two who are
self-organizing so various different
capabilities the scrum team members
would have so each of their capabilities
complement to accomplish the results
required so question number three
what are the responsibilities of this
chrome team
so scrum team is self organizing as i
mentioned earlier
so it is a self organizing team that has
five to seven members and the
responsibilities would include the
development and delivery of working
products during each sprint
now we are seeing the new terminology
sprint so what is the meaning of this
print
now sprint refers to
an iteration a time box iteration
which will have a specific deliverables
to be accomplished as part of it
so self-organizing team
takes that specific working piece what
needs to be delivered so that is a
sprint backlog we call it as
so from the product backlog the features
functionalities which needs to be
delivered as part of
this specific iteration called sprint
time box iteration and those sprint
backlog items are delivered
the output of that sprint would be the
features what is been taken as a working
piece working product
so to demonstrate ownership and
transparency for work assigned to them
so they own it the entire thing assigned
to them there is there should be
ownership
so ensuring the success of daily scrum
meeting by providing crisp and correct
information
so scrum has one event there are five
events basically so one of the events
which happens daily is daily scrum
meeting
where the team
comes with the scrum master so they
would speak about what is that they have
accomplished
from the previous standup to till now is
there anything which is stopping them to
move forward
so giving the crisp updates specific
summary updates so that scrum master
understands the status so any specific
changes or any specific support which
are required scrum master would discuss
separately with those individuals and
get it done so it should be minimum 15
minutes meeting when we say daily
stand-up meeting
so scrum team collaborate with each of
the team members they work together and
they self-organize so next question the
differentiate between a jail and scrum
now it is very essential to understand
the terminology's differences
so if we just end up with looking at a
wrong understanding of each of the
terminologies then explaining will
become difficult so what does it mean by
agile and what it is when it comes to
the terminology called scrum the term
agile refers to ability to move quickly
and easily by becoming more flexible and
adaptable this is what the meaning which
gets associated with the term agile so
many times i have seen people answering
agile is a methodology ager is a
iterative and increment methodology
and also i think when you search through
the popular search engines you may come
across that which is wrong so agile is
the terminology which is used to state
to move quickly and easily by becoming
more flexible and adaptable this we
should keep in mind so if the question
may be like what are agile methodologies
then you can come across like one of the
agile methodologies scrum and you can go
on on various different methodologies
what we have
so scrum is an agile methodology
right the term scrum is the name given
to the agile material methodology which
enables organization to become a joint
right so to become agile obviously there
are various methodologies scrum is very
popular so that is the main difference
so further if we look at agile manifesto
on 12 principles which acts as
guidelines to become a child so there is
something called agile manifesto
four points
clearly articulates what needs to be
focused on to become a child and that
support that is supported through the 12
principles which guides
so scrum is used in projects where
requirements are constantly changing
means i want to become agent so i adopt
scrum
so this definitely
has to align to agile manifesto and take
the guidelines whatever is mentioned in
12 principles of a gel manifesto then
looking at
leadership perspective roles perspective
so manifesto mentions the required
collaboration interactions to become a
child
whereas crumb defines the roles like the
scrum master the product owner the
self-organizing teams which is
cross-functional self-organizing team
so these are the main three roles which
scrum defines
now generally when we say projects we
come across the role like project
manager so do we see such project
managers in scrum answer is no because
the scrum master who engages with team
regularly
more than management they focus on doing
facilitating role to the scrum teams so
that things can be delivered the way it
is required and more flexibility is
given to the team to take the calls to
accomplish the results so scrum master
facilitates whereas the product owner as
i mentioned earlier looks at the product
backlog and prioritizes and provides
what are the features functionalities
needs to be created in the next
iterations
so speaking about flexibility
definitely agile manifesto mentions the
required focus on working software and
focusing on changes
so that's the focus the direction what
it provides so scrum approaches enables
teams to react to changes quickly the
scrum methodology is made such a way the
team
understanding that can able to react and
those changes and modifications are made
visible to the team
so delivery perspective manifesto
provides necessary guidelines on
frequent delivery of product or software
so scrum with time-boxed iterations
called sprints builds
delivers to the users regularly and half
held agile principles
that is very important so delivery here
is as per the user's requirement as per
the customer requirements because
customer when we want to become a child
customer has to involve very closely
stakeholder has to collaborate without
that you cannot become a jack
so next point is about collaboration
agile manifesto stresses on individual
interactions and customer collaborations
so based on this if you look at in the
scrum how are they demonstrating this so
there are various events which happens
in scrum so as i mentioned earlier we
have daily stand-up meetings and other
scrum events like sprint rest
retrospective sprint reviews
daily stand-up meetings which happens
like sprint planning which happens
regularly
so it it becomes a reason for
collaboration and everyone to discuss
and take the call so question number
five
what are the main artifacts of this
chrome process now product backlog
so which consists of list of new
features
changes
which are
looking organization is looking for
to bring into the existing features
changes to existing features
bug fixes changes to the infrastructure
and several other activities to ensure a
particular outcome so product backlog
so then we can speak about sprint
backlog a subset of product backlog
so the sprint backlog contains tasks
that the team aims to complete to
satisfy the sprint's goals so set off
product backlog things are taken put
into spin backlog and those are the
features which are supposed to be
produced as a result as part of that
particular sprint
the team first identifies tasks from the
product backlog that need to be
delivered to achieve a goal so these
tasks are then added to the sprint
backlog
so the team first identifies tasks from
product backlog
as per the priorities
the list which is prioritized in the
product backlog that is taken put into
sprint backlog and then those are
delivered
so next you can think about
product increment the product increment
is the combination of all product
backlog tasks completed in the sprint
and the value of the increments of
previous sprints
the outcome should be in the usable
condition even if the product owner
doesn't decide to release it it is very
important each of the increments which
comes out
so needs to fulfill this
now question number six
how are the product and sprint backlog
different from one another product
backlog versus sprint backlog let us see
a few differences
so product backlog is the list of items
that needs to be completed for
developing the product
which is the list of all the features
functionality consolidated one whereas
print backlog is a list of items to be
completed during each sprint which are
taken from
product backlog
the backlog when it comes to product
backlog the backlog is collected from
the customer by product owner and
assigned to the team whereas
in sprint backlog the teams collects the
backlog from the product owner and sets
up the time frame for the sprint
so product backlog is specific to end
goal ultimate objective whereas print
backlog is spread specific to that
sprint specific iteration called sprint
in scrum
what is that we are going to produce as
part of it
product backlog is based on customer
vision whereas print backlog will vary
based on the product vision defined by
product owner so pre-order test list you
take from the product backlog
so product backlog is independent of
sprint backlog whereas
sprint backlog is dependent on product
backlog reason you we know already i
explained so this is the prioritized
list of backlogs we take from product
backlog and create this uh per specific
product as part of sprint which becomes
spread backtrack
so product backlog
refers to until the project is complete
the product owner maintains the product
backlog
for a sprint backlog when it comes to
sprint backlog each news prints as
backlogs added by the team
as each prints are initiated
so
next question who is the scrum master
and what does he or she do
so a scrum master promotes and supports
the adoption of scrum in the team scrum
master helps everyone to understand the
theory practices rules and values in the
scrum
so scrum master is
playing the role of facilitation
enablement
right
so scum master ensures the team follows
chrome values principles and practices
removes blockages that may hamper the
progress of the project
protects the team from being distracted
ensuring the team delivers value during
every sprint
so next question what happens in daily
stand-up sessions so daily stand-up
sessions
are the discussion which are done daily
that takes place under usually 15
minutes
in duration the objective is to
understand what went well
what tasks are completed from the last
stand-up session
what tasks are pending and the obstacles
the team was facing
if at all any
specific task is not accomplished for
certain reasons so what are stopping
them stopping the team to accomplish
that that needs to be made visible
so that separate meeting can be held to
discuss on that and do the necessary
corrections by taking proper actions
so the objective of this daily stand-up
meeting is to understand the overall
scope and status of the project
further individual discussion can be
taken up after the daily stand-up
sessions
as i mentioned earlier if at all if you
find something is not accomplished as
per the plan
now how do we ensure that is corrected
and why is it happening is there
anything any support is required by the
team to focus on that so something like
that
can be checked out
question number nine what is scrum ban
so scrum ban is a development
methodology that is a combination of
scrum and kanban
so this can be used to meet the needs of
the team
that aims to minimize the batching of
work and to adopt a pull-based system
so kanban is called as pull-based system
so which actually helps in terms of
visualizing what work is in progress
and since it is a visualized visualized
system it is visible to everyone
so
it works
uh in terms of making people become
conscious to take that work and get it
closed quickly
so it's also called pull system because
work is pulled from that particular list
so when this kanban
approach or methodology or thought is
applied in scrum we call it ascramban so
combination of this definitely helps in
terms of making that entire journey
successful and supports the scrum
methodology
so scrumbar includes the structure of
scrum along with the flexibility and
visualization of kanban
so scrumbar is used by the teams that
need to be structure of scrum that has
the structure of scrum and the
flexibility of a flow based method
like on1
so question number 10 what is sprint 0
and spike so the terms print 0 refers to
the short amount of effort put for
creation of vision a rough skeleton of
the product backlog so now we do this
whenever we need to understand certain
things how things looks like
to get certain insights
so this also includes insight towards
estimating the release of products so
you get some vision it gives some
clarity
right so this sprint zero are required
to create project skeleton alongside
research spikes keeping minimal design
develop a small number of stories
completely
have low velocity and be lightweight
so speaking about this spike
so spike is set off activities used in
extreme programming
i think
this was introduced there in extreme
programming that is one of the agile
methodologies
so involving research design
investigation making proof of concepts
etc
so the objective of spike is to reduce
the risk of technical approach by
gaining knowledge which helps
understanding requirements and to
improve reliability so more aware we are
more
clarity we have i think
putting step further will become easier
so informed decisions you can take so
next question what is crumb of scrums
now scrum of scrums is a terminology
used for scaled agile techniques which
is required to control
and collaborate with multiple scrum
teams so when will we come across the
need for collaborating between multiple
scrum teams
so these are the scenarios where
organization has a complex structure
complex in nature where you may require
to handle them
together all of them uh together for
accomplishing the common objective for
business
various crime teams you would have so
scrum of scrum helps in terms of
better collaboration and handle them
easily or better way better control it
is best used in the situations where
teams are working together on complex
assignments just visualizing the system
various different deliverables which are
not a simple deliverables which we can
do with the simple scrum team
instead we have
various different deliverables which
needs to be made and dynamics are too
complex
so bigger projects then scrum of scrum
approaches can be taken
so scaling
the agile methodology to that level
so it is used to establish the required
transparency
collaboration
adaption adoption to the required scale
to ensure the products can be developed
and delivered so whatever the products
are delivered whatever we consider to be
delivered so those needs to
focus on the business objectives which
is very essential
so what is user story mapping
so user story mapping represents and
arranges user stories
that help with understanding the
system's functionalities the systems
backlog
planning releases and providing value to
the customers so first of all we write
user stories to understand the required
features functionality in their user
perspective
now if we map
those user stories which use a story
link to other user story which
functionality links to the functionality
determining that will become easier
so now
user story maps arranges user story
based on the priority along the
horizontal axis
on the vertical axis they are
represented based on increasing level of
sophistications
so this will help in terms of
handling in a regular flow
in a specific flow not regular specific
flow so that things can be done in order
with full clarity
so question number 13 what happens in
sprint retrospective
so after this print review
so sprint completes
so sprint review happens
the sprint retrospective is done
so during this meeting
the lessons learnt what went well
what mistakes we did
what were the issues
so is there any new way of doing things
so all these are discussed so that these
necessary corrections can be considered
in the upcoming iterations the sprints
so data from here is incorporated when
planning the new sprint so the learning
what you had you are going to collect it
what went well what went wrong what was
supposed to be the best approach and how
did we approach it is there any other
way of doing it so these are discussed
and very essential to do it at the end
of completion of each of the sprints
review
question number 14
what is empirical process control in
scrum
so empiricism refers to work based on
facts experiences evidences
observations and experimentation
so empirical process control is
established and followed in scrum
ensuring project progress
and project interpretation is based on
facts of observation so actual facts and
figure is very important any decisions
what we make
any
progression what we make should be
always based on
on ground facts and actual pictures
we should not deviate from it
so these rely on transparency
observation and adoption obviously when
you are working on the data on ground
reality
so you are working on the actual one it
is transparent it is on the observed
data
the mindset of the team and the shift
required in thought process and culture
are very essential to accomplish the
agility required by organization
so mindset of the team is very essential
and adoption of process compliance to
the process the culture the behavior
obviously plays a very important role
when
you do something within the organization
so that needs to be done as per the need
which should complement to the
business objectives
very important and that should be based
on facts not on some
thoughts or assumptions or ideas so next
question is what are some drawbacks of
using scrum so scum requires individuals
who have experience
without whom the project risks
will have a risk of failure
so one does not have a capability
difficult scrum requires team to be
collaborative and committed
so while people collaborating
individuals collaborating itself is a
big challenge in many organizations
so bringing this into the place is very
important when you want to adopt scrum
so scrum requires teams to be
collaborative and committed to ensure
the required results they should work
together
and also they should collaborate with
customers stakeholders
the less experienced crumb master can
cause the failure of the project
so be careful
scrub master is the one who is
facilitator we should understand this
who enable the scrum teams who ensure
scrum teams goes the way we need them to
work
if scrum master doesn't understand this
dynamics does not have the clarity on
this obviously the e or she can not
enable to team to become that
if tasks are not well defined the
project can have any inaccuracies
chrome works better for smaller projects
and would be difficult to scale to large
complex projects that's where we were
discussing on a few questions before
this
scrum of scrum we're discussing about
when it becomes a complex project which
those needs to be handled together which
will become complex
so next question is what are the skills
of a scrum master so a strong
understanding of scrum and agile concept
scrum master should have fine-tuned
organizational skills so when scrum
master is working with the
self-organizing team with various
different capabilities
so unless the organization skills
interpersonal skills if scrum master
does not have
working with them will become difficult
so if scum master should be familiar
with technology that the team uses basic
understanding of that how it works the
dynamics associated with that and scrum
master should have an ability to coach
and teach the team to follow scrum
and its methodologies
and very clear about the terminologies
artifacts
and all the events what happens
so scrum master should have an ability
to handle conflicts and resolve them
quickly
so conflict is a scenario which would
happen for various different reason
however when conflict occurs
the scrum master should not shy away
from it
own it to resolve in the interest of the
project whatever is being done it is
very important
scrum master has to be a servant leader
so it is not like i am a specific
manager or leader of certain kind and i
am doing this with certain way no i am
actually facilitating i am guiding i am
showing certain direction
to the organization so that says to the
team when i say organization speaking
about scrum team
so that they are enabled to take up the
specific project and accomplish the
results accordingly
question number 17
how can
discord be dealt within the scrum team
now the root cause of the issue need to
be identified in a test
complete ownership needs to be
established when you deal with this
and try to diffuse the disagreements so
emphasizing on the focus area that
complements the project
so here when we take up any of the
discussions any of the
opportunities or any actions what we
take
everything should be revolving around
objective of ultimate objective of
whatever we are doing
so when we need to resolve something
when we get into the root causes always
it helps to
look at the actions
in terms of eliminating those causes so
once the causes are eliminated it is
quite obvious you can able to
deal with it and address it with easily
with the right set of actions
so emphasize on focus areas that
complements the project in the sense
that should be the ultimate direction
not my individual interest not that
individual interest i favor this person
i feel that person that's not to be the
case so favoring this solution or
favoring that solution i'm okay with
this particular technology i'm very
happy with this technology not such
thoughts it is the direction what is set
i should move things in that direction
so to establish a common understanding
and to guide the team to the direction
performing continuous monitoring and
providing
complete visibility
very very important
the next question what is a user story
so user stories are an agile software
development project management tools
it provides the team with simple natural
language explanations of one or more
features written from the end user's
perspective
now for example i'm a account holder in
a bank
so first what is the facility a bank
would give to um
account holders there is atm banking
there is net banking there is mobile
banking and there is
over the
counter now when bank is
working on creating certain specific
features or specific mobile app to the
account holders
now what are the things user needs that
needs to be visualized
now if i say the role here is account
holder
as a account holder
i want to
download the statements
of every month
as a account holder i want to download
the statements every month this is what
my requirement is how will you
facilitate this this will provide the
insight towards
how
the bank
what are the features and
functionalities and how these
requirements are can be fulfilled by the
bank and what features functionality
the particular mobile app should have so
that
account holder can download the
statements
so user stories will provide that
insights whatever users so account
holder is not just an user here there
are many users when it comes to mobile
app of a bank
we have
people who monitor it manage it would
develop it
so they need to have a clarity on what
exactly they need and that needs to be
written
as part of user story that what features
functionality can be easily determined
out of it
so a user story does not go into detail
it just mentions as i gave an example it
just mentions
how a certain type of work
will bring value to the end user
the end user in this case could be an
external end users or even internal
customers or colleagues within the
organization so if i am an organization
i produce an hr application i create an
hr application
for claim processing which i don't have
till today
so that is for internal users in the
bank example speaking about external
customers
so user stories also form the building
blocks of agile framework like epics and
initiatives
these help ensure that the team work to
the goals of the organization through
epics and initiatives so further the
requirements for making the user stories
a reality or added later after
discussing with the team so to write a
user story the involvement of the team
members are very essential they should
discuss and come out and agree yes this
is the features functionality which
should be there
user stories are recorded on post-it
notes index cards or project management
software whatever is feasible and
whatever is available there next
question
how are the user stories epics and tasks
different sources stories provides the
team with simple explanation of business
requirements created from the end user
perspective as we saw the few examples
in the previous questions
epics
are the collection of related user
stories they're usually large and
complex
so these epics are created with specific
objectives in mind and user stories are
grouped
so that will form an epic whereas task
refers to the one which are used to
track work
so they are used to further broken down
from the user stories so there's a
smallest unit in the scrum used to track
work a person or a team or two people
usually work on the tasks so these tasks
are these through this task i think the
features functionality what are required
to be accomplished are done so question
number 20
what is print now as i mentioned earlier
in the question number four
so sprint is the terminology
used in the scrum i think we explained
various different concepts as we went
through so sprint is the terminology is
used in scrum which refers to time box
iterations so we understood what is this
iterations
in scrum approaches when we are going
through that
the creation of specific modular feature
which is part of a product is done
during the sprint
the duration of sprint varies between a
week or two so means it's a short
duration
simple few features functionalities are
taken and created so what is velocity
so velocity is the metric used in scrum
that is a measurement of
the amount of work that is completed by
team during the sprint
so this is help to measure how how
things are moving how faster they are
moving
it refers to the number of user stories
complete in single sprint
so this speaks about that speed so our
velocity velocity
uh how faster we are going how slower we
are going this helps to vary the
variations we can do that velocity uh
depending on what business need so what
are the responsibilities of a product
owner
so product owner define the vision of
the project
they anticipate the needs
of the customer and to create
appropriate user stories
so they don't write user stories as such
they definitely have a set of people who
should get involved the team
to write the user stories lot of
discussion has to happen brainstorming
has to happen to write user stories
but
product owner is accountable
so product owner has to evaluate the
progress of the project based on this
backlog what project or product owner
has
and has to be licensed for all product
related questions the team may have
certain questions as prints as the
sprint progresses
the scrum team may have certain
questions clarification relating to the
user stories
those needs to be clarified
what is burn up and burn down charts
so generally when we say chart
it is a graphical representation so burn
up chart is a tool that is used to track
the amount of work that has been
completed
so it is a bar chart the amount of work
completed
the height of the bars keeps increasing
in burn of chart based on what is
completed
which will show the total amount of work
the need to be done for a sprint or a
project
so it is it is a bar chart where each of
the bars keeps increasing in its height
as number of things get delivered
increases
so
burn down charts typically again a
graphical representation a bar chart
so what is pending to be delivered it
shows that now initially we'll have a
bigger bar and as the project progresses
the height of the bars reduces
indicating
what is that is pending for deliverables
it is a representation of how fast the
team is working through the user stories
it helps you to understand that
so it shows total effort against the
amount of work for each iterations
which is helpful for you to see to that
what is pending to
complete
question 24 how is estimation in the
scrum project done
so the estimation of user stories is
done based on its difficulty
a particular scale in which
which is used to assess the difficulty
of user stories
so to analyze
how difficult or easy is this some of
these scales which are used like
numeric sizing 1 to 10
t-shirt sizing like sml excel
fib gnosis series or dog breeds based on
their
value
so many such approaches are taken
what are some risks in scrum and how are
they handled
so first of all we should know what is
risk so some types of risk in scrum are
related to budget people
sprint
product
knowledge and capability
now when we say budget
risk of uh increase
exceeding that allocated budget taking
more
looking for more variations i estimated
for x it is going like x plus delta x so
can we control it we need to look at
that so you need to assess that risk
when what possibilities the cost can
escalate people related like team
members need to be of appropriate skills
and capabilities if they lack that
obviously
difficult it's not about just skills and
capabilities the culture the behavior
the attitude
the energy
this energy that collaboration what
people will have then sprint related in
terms of duration and deliverables
exceeding the duration
addition of scope to that sprint in
between
so that challenges
that difficulties
so product referring to user stories and
epics having ill-defined user stories
and topics not properly articulated
there is no proper visualization when
you look at that user story not
understanding so nobody is explaining it
correctly
so then uh
knowledge and capabilities so it is not
just related to the people here it's a
entire system
everyone was who is involved
with the specific resource with its
capability it can be technology
capabilities also
so when i say risk it basically involves
identification assessment analysis and
defining
risk response plans and implementing
them
now
when i say assess
assessing the risks
should be qualitative as well as
quantitative
so depending on the impact and
probability of a risk
if it is a high impact risk obviously
you are equal to do both qualitative and
quantitative
if a simple one with very less impact
you can take the call accordingly to
what extent you might require to analyze
and have the response plans for it so
once you have implemented and defined
and implemented the response plans
quite obvious you should keep monitoring
it and manage the risks
the risk impacts and probabilities may
vary as the project progresses so we may
require to keep assessing
the identified risk and keep identifying
the new risks as you as we progress in
the project
so these are done on a continual basis
right from starting of the project till
completion the reason i told
it is essential to understand that the
impact of the risk is based on the
proximity of actual occurrence of the
risk
now for example if you start uh working
on something nothing is delivered at the
moment
now if specific risk of peep no people
not available
our customer is not involved initial
stage very initial stage
so
risk impact is accordingly
project would delay in entirety
our
requirement is not very clear it is
delaying
something of that sort of impact you
will have now as the project progresses
almost like 50 of the project complete
now the there is some
challenges or risk associated with
issues are occurring related to
customers involvement
now you are made of project so again you
will have a different kind of impact 50
percent is delivered now you need to
progress because active involvement of
stakeholders including customer is very
important
when you are becoming a child
so when that is not happening as an
example i am taking the involvement of
customers the collaboration part of it
that is not happening now here the
impact level is not equal to the impact
level when when this happens in the
starting of the project same type of
risk what we are assessing
so that is the reason each of the risks
you should keep assessing
the identified one keep assessing as the
project progresses and check on is very
new risk is introduced as the project is
progressing
so next question what are some popular
tools used in scrum so these are the
list
so you can think of github
soho trello
jira software yodex
varies of version one so now what i am
saying is
these are the tools technology tools
so when we say tools we cannot just
limit our thought to technology tools so
what exactly this tool does
what are the techniques used that we
need to be very clear
right the metrics what is measured and
methodology of measuring it and what
processes are used what steps are used
so what needs to be used
so unless we are clear relating to
specific type of project
usage of these tools
may not make any sense you cannot even
implement or customize this for the
requirement what you are trying to
accomplish so you be
clear about it when you are selecting
the tool so 27 how does scrum master
tracks print progress
so we have various different events
which happens in scrum
like daily scrum meetings scrum
retrospective scrum planning
scrum review
and checking on the defects which are
escaped density of the defects
burn down
[Music]
spring burn down
velocity
so so checking all of this
provides the better insight to scrum
master so that tracking the progress of
the sprint will become
easier
so how to deal with the scope creep now
before we understand the dealing with
scope tree we need to understand what is
scope creep
so the term scope creep refers to the
change which is uncontrolled and added
without checking the impact on the
constraints like scope time cost
now what happens is you will be
doing certain or delivering certain
features
now you are forced or you are influenced
or without your knowledge some
additional things are put in place
so which may impact later it may add
value it may not add value later it
doesn't matter but it may lead in terms
of
impact your cost time and
schedules
which is unexplained
and that extra effort what you have put
in extra cost what you put in
will become like
not recognized by customers and you will
not get anything paid for it so
scope to avoid the scope creep to deal
with it one has to ensure close
monitoring of works being done on
day-to-day basis
because scope creep can happen through
team members influencing team members
are influenced by consumer because of
that it may happen
so understanding communicating the
vision to the team for ensuring the
alignment so the team
is very sensitive about that changes
what is happening
then capturing reviewing the project
requirements regularly
against what is delivered
to emphasize
to the team and customer about the
requirements signed off so that someone
will not come and
influence you or
make that additional things to be
delivered
they need not push you right ensuring
any change introduced to go through
change control so no changes
without any proper approval by the
authorities so that
only those what is required to be
implemented is implemented and that is
done formally through the formal change
request
so avoiding gold plating so it is with
different thought process when we say
gold plating
so
we were doing the projects are trying to
add certain things into the scope to
please the customer as an example
doing something additional
providing some additional features and
functionality for which we are not paid
so scro creep is not a terminology used
for it but gold plating is the term used
but however since it is an additional
scoping so we just added here
so don't say that when the moment scope
creep we says that is not gold plating
gold plating is a different direction so
just to explain you
along with scope creep what else would
happen to where the additional
deliverables would come in which is gold
plating so question 29 what is mvp and
mmp which means minimum viable product
and minimal marketing product
so now minimum viable product is a
concept of lean startup which stresses
upon the impact of learning while
performing product development
so this allows one to test and
understand the idea
by getting exposed to the initial
version of the product for target
customers and users so to accomplish
this one has to collect
all the required relevant data and learn
from the collected data
so
the thought behind mvp is to produce a
product to provide access to the users
and to observe how the product is used
pursued and understood
this will also provide
more insight towards what the customers
or users needs are
so when it comes to minimal marketable
product
this refers to the description of the
product which will have a minimal number
of features that
addresses the requirements of the users
the mmp would help
also the organization reduce the time to
market because you have the clarity what
is that we may require to
provide the question number 30 what does
dod means
definition of done right
so dod refers to the collection of
deliverables
which includes written quotes comments
on coding unit tests
integration testing design documents
release notes etc
this would add variable and
demonstratable values to the project
development
so deword is very helpful to scrum while
identifying the deliverables to achieve
the objectives of project for the stated
reasonable
so defining the steps required to
deliver the iterations the usage of
appropriate tool like burn down to make
the process more effective
ensuring on time feedback throughout the
project life cycle
ensuring the walkthrough of the product
backlog items are done and understood
correctly so then creation of checklist
for product backlog item
ensuring the devotee is defined to
become task oriented involving the
product owner for reviewing during this
print and sprint retrospective that is
about dvd the next question how can a
scrum master be a servant leader
it's a very important thing to
understand
so what is the meaning of the servant
leader the term servant leader mainly
stresses on service orientation which a
leader should demonstrate
so today we say every organization is
service organization
even an organization who is producing
card if there is no service orientation
they cannot sell
so more stresses on being service
orientation
the scrum master needs to be facilitator
a guide a mentor etc
this helps the team have increased
involvement and empowerment so now
question number 32 how can one
coordinate between multiple teams so one
of the most common approaches for this
is krum of scrum's meeting so where
members representing each scrum team
discusses the progress
performance issues
risk etc together this is complex
structure what you're speaking about
the frequency of these meetings must be
predefined well articulated well defined
generally scrum master would represent
the particular scrum team on behalf of
that scrum team they would
go and represent the meeting represent
in the meeting
besides having a chief scrum master
who's responsible is
coordination and collaboration among all
scrums who facilitates
these meetings that's it
thank you so much
for
looking at this video referring to
the tutorial
i hope these set of questions will help
you and better equip you when you are
going for the interview
and i wish you all the best
and uh be there tune in so we keep
producing uh a lot of tutorials like
that you can refer learn better
all the best
see you soon in the next tutorial
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you